[Music]
welcome to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast Greg starts
off today's episode with some very
impressive feats of strength and then we
have a huge research roundup segment in
this segment we talked about some recent
research comparing different types of
whey protein Greg takes a deep dive into
the research on phototherapy
we talked about glycogen depletion and
replenishment the use of coffee as a
pre-workout supplement some recent
research on lower back pain and more to
finish off the episode we have an
interview with Ben [ __ ] and we talk
first about power building which is
basically how to train for power lifting
and body building simultaneously and we
also talked to Ben about the subject of
his PhD which is the history of physical
culture if you'd like to support the
podcast by subscribing to our monthly
research review called mass this is a
reminder that the mass Black Friday sale
is currently happening right now you can
get 30% off of all subscriptions with a
large percentage of our profits going to
this year's charity of choice which is
the American Foundation for Suicide
Prevention that sale is happening right
now and it ends December 2nd as always
thanks for listening and enjoy the show
welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast today I'm
joined by a special temporary guest host
named Greg knuckles thanks for inviting
me thank you for accepting my invitation
I tell you what Greg we've got a lot to
get to today so I'm gonna suggest that
we dive right in to feats of strength
yes sir
so I have four things picked out for
today gonna lead with the one that
probably everyone is expecting and that
is this feats of strength segment I feel
like we should just rename it the Julius
Maddox update segment because I feel
like that's what we do a lot but he
recently competed again in the lead up
to this meet he benched 700 for a triple
paused so everyone was expecting big
things coming in he ended up breaking
his own all-time world record he
bench-pressed 744 pounds which is three
hundred thirty seven and a half kilos
that beat his old world record by two
kilos was three thirty five and a half
or 739 and it was good to see this
because as we talked about with the
prior record the press was smooth looked
like one of the spotters hit the bar so
after he got the rack command he just
kind of like dropped to the bar on his
chest it was not a good looking scene I
don't think any of that was his fault
but you know this new world record is
absolutely faultless it is a
picture-perfect bench press it's also
worth noting he got it on his second
attempt the word I heard is that he was
looking for 350 kilos or 771 on his
third but he felt some PEC tightness
after a second so he just decided to you
know shut it down after breaking his own
world record
rather than risk injury so I didn't see
this lift based on how it looked
the 770 does that look like it's like on
the table I mean it's hard to tell
he's one of those types of guys who
either gets it smoothly or mrs. right
comparing the 744 he did to the third
rep of his 704 a triple the 744 looked
easier than that third rep so I do still
think he had something left in the tank
but just watching his lifts it's hard to
tell whether he has ten pounds in the
tank or 40 so I don't know I I'd
probably give it a coin flip yeah I mean
but we know what it's like you're you
got 700 on the bar you're hitting that
third rep it'll sneak up on you you know
in theory sure yeah
so that happened it's awesome he is
pushing bench press into frontiers that
no one else has still making reasonably
consistent progress so you know is he
going to break 800 before anyone else
even breaks 750 who knows I wouldn't be
shocked
so moving on Kahler woolum recently tied
the deadlift world record in the hundred
10 kilo class or 242 pound class
he pulled for 32 and a half kilos or 953
pounds that ties Christoph we're Vicki
he had previously pulled that same
amount but he did it in a deadlift only
meat whereas Caylor woolum did it at the
end of a three lifts meat which you know
tends to take something out of people so
ties the world record but in my book is
slightly more impressive there was a bit
of controversy about this lift so it
looks like kind of like double clutched
to the start a little bit and so in the
rulebook if the plates break off the
ground that is your attempt and it's
just a question of whether you lock it
out or not it kind of looks like the
plates may have barely broken off the
ground then touch the ground again and
then broke the ground again to lock out
so kind of like as he was tensioning
himself he maybe put a little bit too
much mustard into it my take on that
I don't give a [ __ ] double-clutching the
start of a deadlift it doesn't make the
lifts easier folks so I mean personally
I like strength sports because I like
seeing strong people do strong things
and so like that's a rule we're like
whatever it's a rule I don't care about
the rules or like this one specifically
because this isn't it doesn't make the
lifts easier you know it's not like he
hitched it even though I think Hitchings
dumb as well but that that's another
conversation for another day
but it's not even like he did something
that made made it easier like he pulled
it to my eye it actually looked like a
cleaner lift and we're bickies I didn't
think we're bicky's was locked out but
that's also more controversy this is a
very controversial deadlift record all
around but anyway he pulled it he locked
it out and I personally am impressed
that's gonna be if you ever run for
political office the attack ad is gonna
be Gregg knuckles saying I don't care
about the rules what's going right into
the the audio Bank oh man
that's probably true okay so moving on
once more
Jackson Powell if you haven't heard that
name there's a good reason for it
he is 17 years old and I don't know if
he's ever competed I think he has but
you know not like prolifically so if you
don't know the name learn the name
posted a training lift of himself
squatting 800 pounds which is three
hundred and sixty-three kilos high bar
two which was interesting so fun fact
not that many 17 year old squat eight
hundred so the world record for any 17
year old is Joseph Pina he squatted
three thirty six and a half or eight
hundred eight hundred and six pounds
when he was seventeen so this is the
second heaviest squat by a
seventeen-year-old ever caught on video
as far as I'm aware
but the noteworthy thing about it is in
addition to Jackson Powell and Joseph
Pena I think only one other
seventeen-year-old has ever squatted
over 700 and so you know they're just
kind of over there an outlier freak
territory but yeah strong kid and I
strongly assume he is going to keep
getting stronger
so very impressive stuff from him and
then finally I think this is our first
feat of strength that is actually a
failed lift but it is impressive enough
to me that I think it's worth including
Yvonne Makarov who is a strong man from
somewhere in Eastern Europe posted a
video of a very close miss in a training
lift dead lifting 501 kilos or 1104
pounds Eddy Hall famously has the
strongman deadlift record at 500 kilos
Makarov seems to be making a pretty hard
run at that record and it's so you
should go find the video because it's
interesting he he gets it above his knee
pretty fast and pretty smooth and then
[Music]
he like I don't know just fails very
quickly and it was interesting to see
because like he competes in strong man
and strong men can ramp they can hitch
like those are things that are perfectly
allowed and strong man and so generally
if you see a strong man get a lift above
their knees they're gonna lock it out
because they just have more tools in
their arsenal to be able to do so he
posted in the Instagram caption like for
this video that he tightened his suit
too much so he couldn't get a good
breath so it's possible that he like
failed very suddenly because he started
blacking out like he sat the bar down
very quickly and like instantly went to
a knee so you know maybe he had the
strength for it but was just blacking
out not totally sure
but more recently he posted via a video
of himself doing block polls from
Bologna height with 540 kilos which is
eleven hundred and ninety pounds like
almost 1200 pounds so I mean it seems
like he has the lockout strength to
lockout a mere 1100 so you know he
didn't get the lift but it was a damn
close attempt and Eddy Hall's record
doesn't look as safe as I thought it was
and certainly is as safe as Eddy seemed
to think it was but yeah we we very well
may be seen the next 500 kilo deadlift
her soon which is exciting
definitely I'm still just I can't get
over the fact that Julius Maddux appears
to be in his like 14th consecutive year
of noob gains yeah it's just linear
progress on top of progress
dude it's wild he was kind of stalled
there for like two years or so kind of
consistently hitting numbers between
about 650 and 700 and just the last two
years it seems like his training has
really started clicking I don't know
when he linked up with with Josh Bryant
I know that's his current coach you know
maybe he had like stalled and then
that's when he went and started getting
coaching by Josh and that's you know
what really kicked things into overdrive
but man the the last two years from him
have been crazy he's he has talked about
being the first person to bench 800 and
I'll tell you what man I believe it I
mean I have no reason to disbelieve it
with recent history okay so let's move
on to the next segment we've gotten a
lot of good feedback in the past when we
do research round up segments so it's
kind of you know we do some more
in-depth research reviews where we look
at one paper and get really granular
with a detail but the research roundup
segments a little different because we
do kind of like a highlight reel you
know we talk it enough about the study
to really get some good conclusions then
we move on to the next one so we've got
a nice research roundup and one of the
reasons we wanted to do it is because
many of the listeners probably know Greg
and I publish a monthly research review
called mass with our good friends dr.
Mike Sordo dr. Eric Helms I say zord oh
I think he did dr. Mike Soros dr. Eric
Helms and one of the hardest parts of
mass every month is Greg goes through
and does a journal sweep and we get all
these potential articles to review and
trying to narrow it down to like two or
three to choose that month is so
difficult so we end up with this huge
list of studies that were interested in
but don't have the bandwidth to do a
full write-up of and so a lot of the
studies we're going to talk about here
are basically studies that nearly made
their way into mass but didn't you look
like you're about to say something oh I
was going to say that might be your
experience like so in terms of the total
amount of nutrition versus training
studies that get published I think
there's a somewhat comparable amount at
least in terms of like sports nutrition
stuff obviously there's a ton of like
clinical nutrition research that gets
published as well but my experience is
very much the opposite there's like
every month there's probably another I
would say solid four or five studies
where it's like man I wish I wish
Shrek's her Helm's could have tackled
that one I feel like between me and Mike
we've review five studies every month
and I think like more often than not
there's four that are really good and
then it's just kind of like who gets the
fifth and how can we try to make it
sound like it's cool yeah my experience
is very different I feel like I don't
want to speak for Helm's but with all
the stuff coming out in the sport
nutrition world it there it's just such
a moving target there are so many
different topics to to investigate
like man this month we talked about you
know sucralose and its effects on the
gut microbiome and like yeah I tried to
find all the Studies on the human gut
microbiome and it's basically nothing
you know there's still these new rocks
that were kind of turning over every
single month but in any case well I I
think the I think the thing with
training studies is like there are a lot
of topics being investigated that sound
cool but it's kind of one of those
things I mean you you read our stuff so
you know this where it's like the topic
sounds cool but then we actually get
into the full text and we look at the
design and we're like god dammit why did
you do that
right yeah it's like so close and then
you find something you're like I can't
do anything with this yeah so I mean
shameless pitch that's one of the
value-adds of mass like all of us have
done research and have formal training
in research design so like we we see a
lot of things we see a lot of popular
studies get shared around and then when
we pull them up to look at them it's
like ooh there's some pretty major
design issues in this study that we
haven't seen literally anyone talk about
I mean I think part of that is we know a
fair amount about research design I
think a larger part of that is like most
of the people who talk about research on
social media don't bother to ever read
the full text in the first place
but yeah that's that's one of the things
we do for you like not just talk about
what the research found but whether it
was adequately designed to draw the
conclusions that it is attempting to
draw definitely so I'm gonna dive right
in I've got a study picked out here it's
by Castro at all and it is it's called
comparative meta-analysis of the
effective concentrated hydrolyzed and
isolated whey protein supplementation on
body composition of physical activity
practitioners so basically what they're
looking at it's a meta-analysis looking
at different forms of whey protein
looking at how it affects body
composition in people that are
undergoing physical activity so a
meta-analysis we talked about them
before basically you're just searching
the literature
and trying to combine the results of
several studies that are similar in
terms of their design and their research
question so you can summarize the
overall findings in that body of
literature so the reason I wanted to
talk about this study like you mentioned
it's one of those things where I look
through the abstract and some of the
findings I was like wow that's really
surprising if not counterintuitive and
then digging through the results it
makes a lot more sense when you get into
the full text and you say oh okay I see
what's going on and with a meta-analysis
that's really not meta-analysis assuming
you do it reasonably correctly is like
on the researchers side it's like what
do you want me to do I just told you I
was gonna find this stuff and crunch the
numbers so it's no fault of the the
authors for sure but let me get to the
point here so their search yielded eight
studies with a total of 246 subjects
between them and the average duration of
these protein interventions was sixty
four point five days now the interesting
findings related to two fatness and what
they found was that over all the way
protein supplementation interventions
did yield a significant loss of fatness
where things got a little bit
interesting was when they looked at some
of these subgroup analyses so this is
common and meta-analysis where you might
say okay so we found sixty studies and
we found this effect but you know maybe
25 of them of them were in women and the
rest were in men did we maybe see
different results in the you know a
female subgroup versus the male subgroup
or something like that
so it when there's a lot of studies it
makes a lot of sense when there are
fewer studies it's a fairly limited
approach you got to be a little bit
careful with with how how aggressively
you interpret the finding of that type
of a subgroup analysis so what they did
was they looked at some subgroups and
they looked at weigh concentrate versus
whey isolate and they found that the
the reduction of fat mass was found in
the way concentrate studies but not in
the way isolate studies which when you
compare away concentrate and isolate
this it's a little bit counterintuitive
you wouldn't you wouldn't expect that to
be the case and so when you look a
little bit closer at the results of that
comparison what you found was the like I
said the way isolate did not
significantly reduce fat mass but the
the way concentrate did but the non
significant effect of whey isolate was
actually bigger than the statistically
significant effect of whey concentrate
so what really happened there was we
basically had in the the whey
concentrate group very few studies it
actually only had I think I only had
three studies in it but two of them
reported very narrow confidence
intervals and so what that does in a
meta-analysis is basically inflates the
it I should put it the other way it
reduces the p-value to a relatively
extreme amount when you have extremely
narrow confidence intervals for a
particular study it contributes it pulls
a little bit more weight of the analysis
so to speak and so basically what
happened was when we looked at the
overall mean change in fat mass for
concentrate or isolate the effects were
basically the same and in fact the the
mean change for a whey isolate was
bigger than than it was for concentrate
but because the way concentrate had
these very narrow standard deviations
for two of those three studies it was
statistically significant and the other
was not but when you look at that it's
really important with a meta-analysis
not just to look at the p-values but you
got to look at the actual size of the
effect and so it's one of those weird
things where you know if I told you two
different groups did a benchpress
intervention one group increased their
bench by thirty pounds the other one
increased their bench by twenty five but
the twenty five was significant and the
thirty wasn't there's no way you would
look at that intuitively and say oh give
me the one that increases it by 25 yeah
the other
got better buy more it was just because
there was a little more variability it
wasn't it didn't cross that magical
threshold of being statistically
significant yeah I mean so depending on
like the difference and variability it
could influence what you were doing so
you know let's just say theoretically
it's 30 30 pounds plus or minus 30
pounds and 25 pounds plus or minus 5
pounds if you're say a strength coach
for a high school football team and you
really want to make sure that the vast
majority of your athletes improve over
summer workouts you very well may go
with the 25 plus or minus 5 versus 30
plus or minus 30 so you know and I guess
that kind of depends on philosophy like
if you really just want to grow a
handful of freaks and you don't really
care if a fair amount of other people
crash and burn you go with the 30 plus
or minus 30 so in Scituate and that's a
purely theoretical situation I don't
know if I've ever seen a paper that
actually had results like that but
theoretically if there's huge
differences in variants that could
actually be meaningful if like the
consistency of the effect does matter
quite a bit more to you than the actual
magnitude of it but in virtually every
situation like like this one where you
do see something like that where the
thing that has the larger effect size
isn't significant but the other thing is
it's generally like not actually that
meaningful of a difference in variance
it was just like you know slight
differences and one is a p-value of 0.04
and the other one's 0.06 and because
people just [ __ ] turn their brains
off when they read statistics they're
like oh yep one of the matters and the
other doesn't
yeah and I completely agree with you but
I would also add a layer to that when
you're talking about meta-analysis you
also have to keep in mind that some of
the things contributing to that
variability might just be design
differences population differences or
the way the outcome was measured and so
in some cases you
I find it's not that the effect was more
significant or more consistent in this
subgroup it's that they used a more
consistent measurement tool yeah or they
sampled a population that happens to be
more consistent than the other or if
it's a random effects model you just
have simply more studies in there like
that's gonna increase power and decrease
the the variance of your pooled effect
estimate yeah so so meta analyses have
become the thing that really get me
excited these days I don't know why I
just seem to be gravitated toward them
because I think I think they lend
themselves to misinterpretation pretty
frequently but anyway what I was getting
at with this particular study it was one
of those things where that finding jumps
out at you and then you look at the
full-text you're like okay these were a
bit they were basically the same like
the magnitude of change was pretty much
the same one of them just had slightly
tighter standard deviations but at the
end of the day whey concentrate whey
isolate it's the same thing basically so
so that was one of those things where
you look into it a little deeper and you
go oh never mind
same kind of thing they found with their
subgroup analysis that when the whey
protein I'm sorry when the protein
content of the supplement was between 51
percent and 80 percent by weight they
found a significant effect but not when
it was over 80 percent by weight and
that is pretty counterintuitive because
you'd think if the whole purpose was to
look into this protein supplementation
more protein would be better if not as
good you know than a lower percentage
protein product and so that was another
one that caught my eye I think what was
happening there sometimes what you'll
see is you can get a little bit of
artifact in these meta analyses so if a
subgroup only has maybe two or three
studies in it every now and then they
just happen to be the two or three
studies that were most or least
impressive in terms of the magnitude of
effect it's kind of just a game of
chance at that point and so with with
that it's you know if you told me that
you had 16 studies in each subgroup and
the lower percentage protein products
output
the higher percentage one then I'd say
you got something but when we're talking
about looking at such a small number of
studies and trying to find the mean of
these very small groups one study that's
particularly impressive with its
refining with with its findings or
particularly modest in terms of the
effect size that can completely throw
your average and all of a sudden that
subgroup analysis is a little bit skewed
again no faults and the researchers
that's the way it goes sometimes but
it's like one of those things when
you're talking about literally having
two or three studies in a subgroup it's
like pull a coin out of your pocket and
flip it four times if you get heads
three of those four times you're not
going to say whoa this is a special coin
right like yeah when you have really
small samples or a really small number
of studies every now and then we see
little tiny patterns emerge that are not
patterns they're just artifacts you know
so another thing that they found was
they found that the effect on fat mass
was significant for people who were
trained rather than sedentary leading
into the study so like fairly active
people rather than sedentary people at
the time of enrollment but again it was
one of those things where one group the
change was significant the other group
it was not but the mean difference in
terms of fat mass for one group it was a
loss of 0.92 kilos for the other group
is a loss of 0.95 that is the same
change right like yeah if we're gonna
get down to a couple tenths of a kilo as
being the real distinguishing factor
between working and not working yeah
those were the same number the sedentary
subgroup only had two studies in it
there was no chance that was going to be
significant dude the more the more you
tell me about this meta-analysis the
more I feel like this should be like the
poster child study for everyone who
doesn't like frequentist statistics yeah
there's a little bit of that going on
you know it's tough so with these
subgroup analyses I think a lot of
people do them because they're
listen this will be cool we'll be able
to you know explore some patterns in
there and I frankly I'm kind of kind of
guilty of this myself I mean I did a
meta with very few studies and did some
subgroup analyses but in the paper
I begged people not to over-interpret
them and I said by the way I did a
formal moderator test for all of these
none of them were significant these are
purely for forming hypotheses for future
studies do not over and like I must have
had probably six disclaimers begging
people please don't misinterpret it's
not that you can't do it you just want
to make sure that you interpret it
extremely cautiously and have several
disclaimer saying this is purely so that
whoever's gonna run their next whey
isolate study hey maybe you look at
whether they were sedentary or trained
or you know it's to form hypotheses to
to help researchers move this body of
literature forward so yeah there are
some dangers with meta analyses for sure
but but they're also a really powerful
tool so it there's a little bit of a lot
of people have love-hate relationships
with meta analyses because they can be
so informative but they can also be
misinterpreted pretty egregiously
sometimes now when it comes to fat free
mass there was no effect in any of the
scenarios that they investigated and
that shouldn't be super surprising when
it comes to the protein literature I
think it's I think we've got enough of
an understanding about what protein does
and what it doesn't that it's safe to
say that the effects of protein
supplementation particularly for for fat
free mass or lean mass they're going to
be entirely contextual so you need to
make sure that this intervention is
changing total protein intake from less
optimal to meaningly more optimal in
terms of their overall protein intake
and the effect of that protein
supplementation is going to depend on
their training status it's gonna depend
on their training stimulus their overall
diet there are so many factors that come
into play so it's one of those things
when you read a study and says
whey protein didn't help with with lean
mass they didn't just debunk whey
protein you just saw a study in which
all those contextual factors weren't in
place to actually really highlight the
potential benefit of a whey protein
supplement so so this is one of those
studies like I said you look at it and
you're like oh I kind of want to talk
about this to make sure people aren't
going to over-interpret some of these
subgroup analyses and run with them and
and make conclusions that aren't
accurate like sorry I only have proteins
that are less than 80 percent protein by
weight because I know they're better
it's like no they're like almost exactly
the same I'm honestly wondering where
they got those proteins from in the
first place because generally when you
see isolates it's like 90 95 percent
plus protein by weight but I mean even
most concentrates are in the 80s range
yeah I don't know it may be they were
maybe you had some carbohydrate in there
maybe that that might be a way to do it
you know like there's back in the day
the n-c-double-a said that you couldn't
give protein supplements to athletes for
I assume a reason I don't know what it
would possibly be but so what they said
was like I think it was I think the
threshold was 30 percent it was like
elite and no more than 30 percent of the
calories can come from protein in the
interest of safety or amateurism or you
know insert whatever Madlib you want to
put in there and I'm pretty sure they
got rid of this rule but so what they
would do is they'd be like here's the
collegiate protein powder and it was the
same protein powder with like 60 grams
of sugar added to it to try to and to
try to add enough calories that that the
protein provided like 29.9%
so so maybe there was some some
carbohydrate contributions there dude so
I remember when I was first getting into
lifting you know I was like 14 years old
and a dumb ass like I didn't know
anything and a big guy at the gym told
me that oh man it like if you want to
get big if you want the best protein
supplement on the market you got to go
with the muscle milk
that's like the best thing it has all
this extra stuff in it it's gonna make
You huge so I remember going to the
muscle milk website and looking to see
what their products were and they they
did have like just regular muscle milk
and then a more expensive like muscle
milk Pro and it said on the label
something like you know preferred by in
situ like the best in c-double-a
football teams or whatever and I
remember looking at the label I was like
this is the same [ __ ] product but
there's like less protein per serving
[ __ ] ton of malt oh dextran I'm 14 I
don't know what that is
but whatever it's not protein and it's
like 25 percent more expensive like dude
you know supplement companies [ __ ]
love to that rule because maltodextrin
is so much cheaper than protein but they
just throw that in and then probably are
able to make the product more expensive
because they can say like used by
n-c-double-a athletes you know so yeah
for sure so before we move on to the
next study I've got my my two big
take-home points about meta-analyses
number one the beauty of a meta-analysis
is that it gives you a cooled effect
size the magnitude of the effect is the
beauty of the meta-analysis way too
frequently people get bogged down in the
p-value most of them the power is
inflated just because you've got several
studies in the mix anyway but but the
thing is like especially with these
subgroup analyses they can go the other
way where it's like you only had two in
the subgroup it wasn't going to be
significant unless the effect was
enormous so what I would encourage
people to do when you're looking at a
meta-analysis look at the size of effect
as the the most important thing you're
looking at how consistent is it and then
start worrying about the p-values and
all that stuff okay but don't don't just
get caught up in the p-value and forget
to worry about how big the actual effect
was because no one cares about a super
tiny effect with a p-value of 0.05 it's
not doing anything for you if the
small in the first place the other
take-home point and this this applies to
meta-analyses but also just about any
study in our field where they measure
two groups over time if one group
improves to a significant level and the
other group improves but in a non
significant level based on their
p-values that doesn't mean there was
like an interaction it doesn't mean that
their responses were wildly divergent
right so two groups could respond almost
the same way maybe one group had a
p-value point oh four the other had one
0.06 every now and then that's a kind of
a extreme example but you'll see people
who say wow this one treatment worked
and the other one totally didn't and
with those p-values their responses were
essentially the same so so when that
applies to subgroup analyses and a lot
of other studies in this field as well
look for interaction tests look for
moderator tests those are what actually
tell you if the responses were indeed
divergent in nature yeah and you still
see that even in the published research
show up all the time like every month
everybody I mean it's so that's not just
like you know social media not being
good at interpreting research no that's
that's like very poor interpretations of
research in the research yes that gets
by peer review every single month and
we'll probably until we're dead Gregg
sweet yeah all right now Greg keeps us
in a job yeah now previously you'd
talked a little bit about photo therapy
and I believe you have an update for us
about photo therapy I do so on the last
non Q&A episode of the stronger by
science podcast I talked about photo
therapy a little bit when we recorded
that episode it was I don't know maybe
like 36 hours after I found out how far
behind this body of literature I was and
so to be clear I can turn through a lot
of literature in 36 hours but you know
not even close to an entire body and so
within like 48 hours of recording that
podcast I was like [ __ ] I just learned a
lot more stuff that I
I would have included so this is just a
really quick update
so just to recap from the last episode
talked about photo therapy and the
things I leaned into the most or that
there is pretty solid and consistent
evidence that photo therapy can improve
acute performance it can improve force
output I wasn't sure why last time I dug
up some more papers it turns out photo
therapy increases intracellular calcium
levels which improves excitation
contraction coupling a little bit so
that largely explains the increase in
force output so that's cool for strength
athletes but then it also just improves
other training performance by
essentially making oxidative metabolism
a little bit more efficient by allowing
oxygen to dissociate from hemoglobin and
myoglobin a little bit more efficiently
in helping a couple of the cytochrome
complexes of the mitochondria function a
little bit more efficiently so it
increases stuff like rep performance or
time to task failure during isometric
tasks really good stuff
another thing that there's quite a bit
of evidence supporting is that it
improves recovery from resistance
exercise so you know things like
decrease in muscle soreness lower levels
of creatine kinase etc etc oh and in
actual improvements in rate of
performance recovery so you know you do
a fatiguing session you test force
output 48 hours later if you had photo
therapy done after the training session
force tends to have recovered a little
bit more in the 24 to 48 hours following
training so that was the stuff that I
had read up on the most prior to the
last time I talked about this and one
thing I noted is that a lot of times
things that improve recovery actually
don't help longitudinal training
outcomes so they don't actually help you
get bigger and stronger and sometimes
they actually go the opposite direction
so you know if you take a high dose of
insets
like non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs before a training session
you're probably not gonna be a sore the
next day or the day after but at least
if you're young and healthy it's
probably gonna compromise strengthen
hypertrophy over time there's some
conflicting evidence with older adults
so older adults may actually get more
hypertrophy if they take NSAIDs
that's another discussion for another
day
similar with high-dose antioxidants may
help improve recovery a little bit but
also compromise long term training
outcomes same thing with ice baths that
improves especially like functional
recovery so things like force and work
capacity but now we have like three or
four studies showing that that decreases
longitudinal training outcomes so you
can't just assume that's something that
improves recovery actually helps make
you bigger and stronger over time and so
one of the things I noted is that I did
find one study showing that photo
therapy actually improved strength and
hypertrophy outcomes over time but I I
was kind of more tentative about that
because that was the only study looking
at longitudinal outcomes that I had come
across at that point because you know
when we recorded last time I'd mostly
been reading about the acute stuff so
since then I came across a review by
Farrah resi at all titled
photobiomodulation in human muscle
tissue in advantage in sports
performance question mark and within
this review
they kind of collated and brought
together all of the longitudinal studies
that had been done to that point looking
at the effects of photo therapy on
long-term training outcomes so there
were there were seven in total three of
them aren't all that relevant to us so
one of them was looking at whether doing
photo therapy before or after a training
session was better for long-term
outcomes and it was pretty similar but
that you know it's not comparing photo
therapy to not using photo therapy one
of them looked at
cycle ergometer training so you know
basically cycling training which very
well could be cool and useful to someone
I'm personally not all that interested
probably not super interesting to most
listeners of this podcast but I can just
give you the cliff notes on that it did
improve or it did decrease quadriceps
fatigability during an isokinetic knee
extension test after cycle ergometer
training using photo therapy so you know
that's potentially interesting for
endurance athletes listening to this and
then the other one that again is
probably not all that relevant is one
where the only functional outcome they
were looking at was a vertical jump
performance and the the longitudinal
aspect of the study was two weeks of
training and I don't think you can
really do anything with that so those
were three of the studies there were
four more though that we're looking at
longitudinal outcomes that probably are
useful and interesting to the people
listening to this so the first one is
the Baroni study I mentioned last time
so subjects in that were untrained males
they were doing eccentric knee extension
training for eight weeks and basically
photo therapy helped everything so they
looked at several muscle thickness
measures that increase more in the photo
therapy group 15.4% versus nine point
four percent they looked at isometric
peak torque of the quads that increased
by twenty and a half percent versus
thirteen point seven percent again with
the larger increase in the photo therapy
group and eccentric peak torque
increased by more as well so thirty two
point two percent versus twenty percent
moving on
there was actually a really cool twin
study performed by the same person who
authored the review Farah resi title is
Effects of light emitting diode therapy
on muscle hypertrophy gene expression
performance damage and delayed onset
muscle soreness : case control study
with a pair of identical twins so as the
title alludes to the subjects were just
a pair of identical
twins one of them they both trained for
12 weeks three times a week one of them
had photo therapy performed on them
after each training session the other
did not
leg press increased in both of these
individuals so in all of these numbers
I'm about to read the larger increase is
in the one that received photo therapy
so leg press increased fifty three
percent versus twenty eight percent knee
extension one rep max increased thirty
seven percent versus twenty percent the
one receiving photo therapy had lower
creatine kinase levels throughout the
entire study so that is again a marker a
muscle damage had lower measures of
subjective muscle soreness throughout
the study and this one also assessed
hypertrophy they looked at by muscle
volume which increased by twenty percent
in the one receiving photo therapy
versus five percent in the one who
didn't and they also looked at some gene
expression stuff so there were larger
reductions in gene expression for
interleukin-1 beta and myostatin in the
one receiving photo therapy so
interleukin-1 beta is an inflammatory
marker myostatin is obviously an
inhibitor of muscle hypertrophy so those
gene expression for both of those genes
decreased more in the one receiving
photo therapy and there was a larger
increase in mTOR gene expression in the
twin receiving photo therapy mTOR again
is implicated and probably the main
hypertrophy signaling cascade do that's
wild 20 percent versus five percent yeah
and so like that's especially noteworthy
because we can't say like oh maybe it's
just like sampling variability therefore
they're identical twins yeah genetics
yeah yes for real so one thing worth
noting is contrary to popular opinion
identical twins aren't actually
genetically identical they were when
like they split in the womb but people
do actually accumulate not just
epigenetic
changes but some degree of genetic
changes over time just due to like gene
damage and whatnot you can have like new
genes inserted by viruses and I think
monozygotic twins also have differences
in like copy number variation even like
when they do split I didn't know that
that's interesting yeah so they're not
perfectly identical but you would still
assume not a bad control though yeah
yeah you can still very safely assume
that they're genetically similar enough
that differences in genes aren't a
aren't explained a 4-fold difference in
hypertrophy you know how like one of the
things we talk about sometimes is like
the new trend is to just arbitrarily
split your sample into responders and
non-responders yes you know somewhere on
a college campus a couple twins sign up
for a study you know that at least one
time in history one was a responder and
one wasn't oh sure it's always so
arbitrary I'm like what are you actually
splitting yeah okay so that was study
number two number three title is effects
of low-level laser therapy parentheses
808 nanometers close parentheses on
physical strength training in humans
subject here earth subjects here were 36
untrained men they trained leg press for
12 weeks received the laser therapy at
the end of each training session and so
one Brett Max leg press increase 55% in
the photo therapy group versus 26% in
the non photo therapy group they looked
at increase in isokinetic knee extension
peak torque that increased by seven
point three eight percent in the photo
therapy group versus three point one six
percent and the other group they looked
at thigh circumference so I guess they
didn't have that's weird that they had a
dynamometer but not any way to like
directly assess eye perch for you but
whatever they looked at thigh
circumference as a measure of
hypertrophy pretty rough measure but it
is what it is you
increased by 4.5 2% in the phototherapy
group versus 2.75 percent in the other
group one thing worth noting is that the
difference in leg press 1 rep max in
this study was statistically significant
the increase in isokinetic torque and
thigh circumference wasn't weren't
significant but I kind of think that's
because they made some weird statistical
choices here so they used a Cruz Cal
Wallis test rather than just like a
two-by-two ANOVA which is weird because
generally you would only use that test
if the assumptions of ANOVA had been
violated and they just said that they
decided they were going to use that
preemptively which is a really weird
thing to do because unless there is a
good reason to not use an ANOVA using a
Cruz call Wallis test is just going to
decrease statistical power so like yeah
and it's not even like it's not even
like a conservative safer option is
right you're losing detailed information
from your data unnecessarily
correct unless you needed to do it yeah
it's not just a matter of like you know
choosing a more conservative post hoc
test right
so that decision wasn't explained in the
text just kind of eyeballing some of
these bar graphs all they show is like
pre and post values they don't show like
change and standard deviation of the
change so it's so unless we assume that
the very the variability and the changes
were super crazy I kind of think that
maybe isokinetic knee extension torque
would have been a significant difference
and maybe leg circumference wouldn't
have been if they had done in ANOVA but
that's just a kind of like minimally
informed to guess here anyway weird
stats it is what it is
but you know the significant difference
again was in favor of phototherapy and
the two non significant differences also
leaned in favor of phototherapy in that
study and then the fourth one of this
group is by Toma and colleagues title is
low level laser therapy associated with
a strength training program
on muscle performance and elderly women
: a randomized double-blind control
study this is probably the one that
stronger by science listeners would care
about the least just due to the
population because you know it's elderly
women we know statistically most of you
people are men under 40 like that's
that's the fitness industry if you're a
male content creator we have a lot of
female listeners but not a lot of
elderly female list know so our audience
is absolutely more diverse than just
about everyone else I've talked to yeah
but you know more diverse means we're
like 68 percent male instead of 85 right
yeah still like fairly skewed I just
want to let all the ladies listening
know that we appreciate them oh we
absolutely do but yeah so I know that a
decent amount of the audience will care
less about this study however I think
this is a very important study from a
scientific perspective because if you
have a treatment that only works in a
very specific population that tells you
that you know maybe there is only
there's something like physiological
physiologically different about that
population that makes it effective but
maybe it's not as generalizable but so
when you have most of the studies on
healthy young men and then you have
another study on elderly women that is a
very substantially different population
and so if you wind up seeing a similar
effect in that population as well that
lets you know that you know whatever the
treatment is doing is probably you know
going to be more likely to apply to all
humans versus just a specific population
of humans so very important study so
subjects were 48 elderly women they did
eight weeks of leg curls and knee
extensions and so in this study as well
they looked at knee extension one rep
max increased by thirty one point eight
percent in the photo therapy group
versus 21 percent in the other group
they also looked at several isokinetic
variables so in like
multi rep test they looked at total work
performed power and peak torque this
study also had weird stats so it would
have been a very ideal study to you know
use like two by two and Nova's on but or
like two by six I guess and so you had a
bunch of different measures whatever but
instead her for all of the the various
measures they just did to one-way ANOVA
z-- instead of various two-way ANOVA z--
and so they just did like pre and post
and they looked to see whether the
groups differed at pre and looked to see
whether they differed at post which
again like you're not going to be able
to get an interaction effect there to
see if like the actual changes were
different so again it's hard to tell but
there were graphs and just kind of
eyeballing the graphs like certainly the
the nominal values of isokinetic work
power and peak torque increased more in
the phototherapy group but since they
didn't actually do the appropriate
statistical tests on like whether those
increases were significantly larger it's
hard to say but they were certainly
nominally larger you know the thing
that's most frustrating about that but
as like let's say you didn't want to do
the two-way anova because you didn't
want to deal with the interaction and
the theoretical underpinning that
requires some degree of thought right
they could have just done the one way
and Cova on the post and just use the
pre values as a covariant the
interpretation would be just as easy and
it's literally just the click of a
button
in most softwares that's just so
frustrating and in fact that actually
that actually tends to outperform i'll
perform a two-by-two anova that there
has been some simulation studies where
they kind of simulate a bunch of data
sets the the one-way an Cova on post
tests using pretest as the covariant is
in many cases better but pretty much
always at least as good as the
two-way anova for the four people out
there that are interested in that well
I'll tell you what that's not what they
did that is not what they did so and and
by the way I know I just said almost
always for a stats decision so just
don't yell at me I know you shouldn't
oversimplify like that I'm sure there
are certain scenarios where I'm wrong so
don't yell at me
well of the six people who know what
you're talking about at least one of
them is very upset right now
pretty much yeah okay so the one thing
we can say for sure is the one rep max
knee extension increased more in the
phototherapy group the other measures
again increased nominally more in the
phototherapy group but hard to know if
if those differences were significant so
anyway those were the studies in
aggregate if you look at the measures of
either one rep max azure like peak
torque values in seven measures across
four studies mean increase was thirty
three point eight percent in the
phototherapy conditions versus eighteen
point four percent in the other
conditions which is almost a two-fold
difference not too shabby
and more than a two-fold difference in
hypertrophy opiate in fewer measures so
three measures across three studies
13.3% versus five point seven percent so
basically I think I I mean I definitely
under sold the amount of longitudinal
studies there were on phototherapy the
last time I talked about this on the
podcast seems pretty solid one thing
worth noting is like for studies means a
lot more than one study and especially
when it's for studies who all have
broadly similar findings you know so
it's it's a general finding that has now
been replicated three times which is
pretty cool with no evidence against it
so that's that's good
certainly more studies would be very
much appreciated because you know even
for very consistent studies it's still
just for studies and the other thing
worth note
all of these studies used untrained
lifters I have to assume that if you did
these studies on trained lifters
certainly like the absolute amount of
improvement in both groups would be
lower I kind of assume that the relative
value that you get from photo therapy
would be smaller as well just because
like it it seems to increase
intracellular calcium that's a good
thing and also like make oxidative
metabolism work a little bit better
those are things that also just change
with resistance training so it is
possible that it wouldn't well I guess
it's possible that it wouldn't do
anything and certainly possible that the
the magnitude of the effect would be
smaller and trained lifters versus
untrained so like that's it that's an
important caveat to point out but just
based on the literature that we do have
it seems really promising it seems
really effective and just kind of
reinforces what I said the last time
like it's surprising to me that no one's
talking about it because I mean it it it
seems to improve all aspects of training
it improves performance in the gym
it improves recovery after training and
it helps you get bigger and stronger
over time like I don't know man
like I see a lot of people talking about
trivial [ __ ] that like maybe affects one
of those three things to a much smaller
degree do I know you want to take a
swipe at beta-alanine so just do it
people still talk about beta-alanine why
the [ __ ] do people still talk about
beta-alanine like it doesn't do hardly
anything for for performance like in the
durations that most resistance training
takes place and so like if [ __ ] makes
your skin crawl improves performance by
like 1.4 percent or whatever the [ __ ] it
was in the last meta-analysis and like
people still talk about it like it's a
good thing like I don't know
like let's talk about photo therapy and
just shut the [ __ ] up about beta-alanine
let's just talk about lasers you know I
hear you know it is
prizing I mean I remember the first time
on social media I saw somebody doing it
and I was like oh boy here we go again
right I I just immediately because it
looks crazy
the general idea yeah I mean I never
looked into it more cuz like I've known
about this general premise for for a
decade like a physical therapist that
worked with one of the first guys I
trained with like I met him we chatted
for a while he was like oh you should
come down to the clinic at some I was
like dealing with a hamstring strain he
was like you should come down to the
clinic I can get that hamstring to heal
up in half the time I got this laser
it's gonna get your right and like even
as like a [ __ ] 16 year old kid I was
like come the [ __ ] on like it's a laser
like you can't tell me that a laser is
gonna help my hamstring heal faster
turns out it probably can like there's a
pretty large amount of rehab literature
on laser therapy as well but I mean when
I heard about that when I was a gullible
child I was like this has to be [ __ ]
so I think I just never looked into it
more because my first impression was
like there's no way this is true yeah
but it seems like it is the first time I
saw it it was the person who was doing
it and kind of posting about it was
somebody who does tend to be susceptible
to the newest just absolute BS on the
market right so like it's just the
newest ridiculous supplement and just
all the weird modalities that show up
for six weeks and everybody's doing them
and then you never hear about him again
so I was like oh okay on to the next on
to the next one but no I've been stunned
them you know we've talked about this
you and I've taught it talked about it's
probably three times now and there's
research but they call that science I
guess yeah like apparently it does stuff
it's wild that's cool I mean as I still
I still retain my skepticism of consumer
grade products that I expressed the last
time we talked about this on the podcast
but yeah I mean the more and more I read
about the actual science of it the more
and more Sullivan it I am conceptually
if anyone's listening to this and
they're looking for a reasonably cheap
but possibly impactful study to do do a
validation study on a consumer-grade
phototherapy
product they range anywhere from about a
hundred bucks to 300 bucks you know you
could probably rock that with a
reasonably small grant like in if it
turns out that any of them work really
well man I'm all in in an owl note I
gain nothing from saying any of this I'm
not I'm not in the the pocket of big
laser I just think this is really cool
and I am stunned that I was this
ignorant about it yeah well you weren't
alone
nobody's talking about it one thing that
people do talk about it's carbs that's a
jarring segue silky-smooth yeah so
there's a study it was a meta-analysis
kind of about glycogen replenishment and
this was a study by Macklin at all I had
considered doing it for a mass issue
decided not to and then somebody a
Joshua Hockett actually emailed me and
was like hey have you seen this you
should you should write something about
it so I'll meet you halfway Joshua I'll
talk about it so if you're thinking okay
I don't really care about glycogen
depletion who would it there actually is
some application for a lot of different
people so if you're a power lifter and
you're cutting weight trying to make
weight for a meat there's a decent
likelihood that you might be depleting
your muscle glycogen and might need to
replenish it in a fairly tight
turnaround if you're any kind of sport
athlete certainly doing a vigorous
amounts of exercise high volumes of it
during your competitive season you you
might need to make sure you have your
glycogen repleted for competition
certainly any weight sport athlete that
does a lot of weight reduction and then
bodybuilders um you know everybody tries
to micromanage
during peak week one of the things you
really can make a meaningful impact on
is whether your muscles are full of
glycogen or flat and depleted so the
purpose of this semi meta analysis it
was more a systematic review the purpose
was to look at the extent of muscle
glycogen depletion through different
modes of exercise and then also to look
at different dietary approaches for
replenishment of depleted glycogen one
of the reasons I wanted to talk about
this was because I thought the
terminology was hilarious so they you
know normally you'll see in a study
they'll be like we called this effect
size trivial and this effect size small
and this effect size moderate well they
put in the huge category which I had
never seen maybe that's a standard thing
I mean I do supplement research so small
is enormous and moderate doesn't happen
when you're talking supplements so I'm
not used to these huge effect sizes
maybe that's the thing but turns out
when you do a very specific glycogen
depletion protocol the effect size on
muscle glycogen levels is technically
huge so that there was no surprise there
but what they did look at with some of
the characteristics of the studies that
caused really big depletion of muscle
glycogen so if you're out there and
you're thinking I want to deplete my
muscle glycogen either because I'm
trying to super compensate for
competition or because I'm just trying
to shed glycogen weight or whatever the
case may be your reason for depletion or
if you're doing exercise like this and
you're wondering will this make me
deplete it that's another way to look at
it usually longer duration stuff and
bouts that include both low and fairly
high intensity work in the middle those
were the ones that really depleted
muscle glycogen so usually the ones that
were over 60 minutes total and had some
really heavy-duty high-intensity kind of
spurts within those 60 minutes so if you
think you go on a bike at like a normal
kind of low to moderate steady state
pace have a few bouts mixed in where you
really grind it for a little bit and
then
kind of recover on a lower intensity you
know a little stretch of lower intensity
kind of going back and forth that's
pretty much what you're looking at the
challenge with glycogen depletion is you
need the duration of the of the bout to
be long enough to actually get the job
done and burned through some substrates
you know if you think you're gonna go
and do a series of 10-second sprints
ain't gonna do it you're gonna burn
through a bunch of phosphocreatine
you're gonna make a bunch of
phosphocreatine you're gonna be going
back and forth obviously you're gonna
you're gonna get some some glycogen
depletion in the process but if you're
trying to maximize your efficiency you
would do this kind of at least an hour
just to make sure you're burning through
that substrate with enough total work to
get the job done now on the
replenishment side of thing that that's
what I find to be most useful for most
people that are listening they did look
a little bit at single studies that were
comparing types of carbs so you can look
at complex versus simple carbohydrates
so starch type carbohydrates versus
sugars there's some studies looking at
small molecular weight versus you know
larger molecular weights there are some
modest differences here and there with
individual studies but really I don't
think it makes a lot of sense to to get
bogged down in those granular details I
think the most important things you want
to worry about when you're trying to
restore your glycogen is the timing of
the carb refeed and the amount of the
carb refeed yeah so I'm I'm skeptical
that the small meat small molecular size
is slightly better
right that's what you have here on this
outline because I learned from tea
nation that the key to recovery is the
high molecular weight stuff the highly
branched cyclic dextran which is
probably the most sciency phrase I knew
when I was like 17 oh yeah because of
tea nation ads so I am quite quite
honestly shocked to hear that that's not
the most scientifically rigorous
supplement brand on the market yeah you
can find it you can't trust
Biotest who can you trust I don't know
man
you you can find these little individual
studies that might indicate some of
these granular details matter but the
really important factors like the
molecular weight stuff I'm just not that
interested maybe I'm way off base here
but I mean my lab we did a study looking
at carbohydrates of different molecular
weights it didn't matter at all what I
think is most important there is a
post-workout window when we're talking
about glycogen repletion so a lot of
times people have seen these studies
about saying like a post-workout window
doesn't matter those are really looking
at protein for the most part when we do
exercise and we've got our muscles
contracting the glute for translate the
glute for transport proteins translocate
to the the outer region of the muscle so
they can help bring carbohydrate into
the muscle and stored as glycogen so
that glute for translocation that is a
transient effect it happens in response
to exercise and then it goes away so you
really want to capitalize on that
post-workout period if your interest is
in completely maximizing muscle glycogen
replenishment also during this time
immediately post-workout there's some
additional blood flow to the muscle kind
of residual from the workout that might
facilitate some of that nutrient
delivery so within the first 2 hours
after a glycogen depleting workout that
that's a really good opportunity to make
sure that you are are getting that
glycogen replenished especially if it's
time-sensitive if you do a depleting
bout and you don't need to use that
muscle group for another 48 hours it
doesn't matter you really don't have to
worry about it but if you're you know
doing this glycogen depleting exercise
and you need to make sure that you're
completely repleted in terms of glycogen
for about that's in 16 hours or 24 hours
then you might want to take a closer
look at it now the common approaches
that they looked at in the studies in
this particular paper they would
basically give a bolus of carbohydrate
every 30 minutes or 60 minutes or two
hours and generally speaking there
wasn't a huge difference between them
but I think one thing to keep in mind is
that glucose and galactose use different
intestinal transporters than fructose
and so what that means is it probably
makes sense to make sure that whatever
carbs you're eating are going to be
broken down and absorbed as a
combination of glucose and galactose and
fructose so glucose transport it's its
absorption in the intestines it maxes
out around 60 grams per hour some people
estimate it to be a little bit higher
than that but for the sake of argument
let's be conservative and say 60 now if
instead of having a pure glucose bolus
of carbohydrate if you had a two-to-one
ratio roughly of glucose to fructose
then you could probably get away with
absorbing 90 grams of carbs per hour so
I think the easiest recommendation would
be shooting for somewhere in the
ballpark of 60 to 90 grams of carbs per
hour you could have a bolus roughly each
hour or you can have a bolus twice as
big every two hours that should be
enough to get the job done and I think
leaning toward a roughly two to one
ratio of glucose to fructose makes a lot
of sense and then certainly it can be a
mixture of starches and sugars and all
that stuff but generally speaking you
want some degree of glucose some degree
of fructose ideally somewhere near a
two-to-one ratio another fun fact about
glycogen repletion is that caffeine can
actually help a little bit it's not
gonna make or break your glycogen load
but caffeine can be useful which leads
me to another paper recently that I'm
not gonna get too much too far into the
details on this one but did you have
something to say about glycogen I had
something to say about Biotest okay what
do you got so dude I forgot how
ridiculous this product was so if you're
if you're old like us and you were on
the Internet
in the Anaconda protocol dropped that's
what that's what all the memes were
about just because like you can't tell
me that that wasn't intentionally sexual
that that was one of the most ridiculous
marketing campaigns ever I forgot just
how I mean whatever like if they can get
people to pay the price like market sets
the rates whatever I get that but I
forgot just how much of a ripoff plasma
was so that's where that's where they
were talking about the benefits of
highly branched cyclic dextran all the
time so tracks just tell me what would
you pay for a reactive a reactive pump
activator a brutal workout formula if
you will which perserving has 38 grams
of carbs 15 grams of protein a little
citrulline malate and a little beating
I mean 75 cents per serving maybe a
dollar
how does 70 bucks for 20 serving sound
that's higher than I got about two and a
half bucks per serving yeah it's a
little above what I was putting on the
table
that's outrageous aspect yeah I mean how
much is a little citrulline I don't know
dirt cheap I mean I mean what was the
dose to say it's in a proprietary blend
so it's not listed so you know it's not
much I mean the the proprietary blend
includes the protein and carbohydrate so
that that's where can I math that's
where that's 53 grams of a 65 gram total
formula so I mean like some of the some
of the things here at the end like
magnesium citrate tri basic sodium like
there's probably not that much of that
so it might be appropriately dosed
citrulline malate and betaine even
though I am still skeptical because it
is a proprietary
formula but I mean just the fact that
you know it's 65 grams per serving and
close to two-thirds of that is
carbohydrate and it's two and a half
bucks of serving that's wild yeah well
you know it's a stand up company these
are good people so we don't want to
disparage their name or their product
I'm sure it's I'm sure it's terrific
sure sure sure
perfect okay now I had a really good
segue and you just stomped all over it
with this insertion coffee coffee yeah
there you go
so like I was saying after after reading
so much bio test sales copy boy am I
tired I could do with a stiff cup of joe
take it away perfect thank you so
there's a recent paper by Pickering and
Gurjit the title is is coffee a useful
source of caffeine pre exercise and
basically what they what they concluded
I'm jumping right to the highlights here
they said there's limited evidence that
caffeinated coffee has the potential to
offer
Urgo Janke effects similar to those of
caffeine anhydrous which is basically
just supplemental caffeine at first I
read that and I thought they were saying
like that there's a lack of evidence I
think what what they're getting at is
there is some evidence but it'd be great
if there were more that there aren't
that many studies looking at coffee
specifically as an ergogenic aid but
what we have would indicate that it is
pretty equivalent in terms of its
organic effects and what they also noted
was that co ingesting caffeine with
decaffeinated coffee so if for some
reason a person in the world were
inclined to have decaf coffee and mix
some caffeine into it
the decaffeinated coffee does not
detract from the ergogenic effects of
the caffeine now the only reason I bring
this up we've talked about caffeine
plenty on the podcast the reason I bring
it up is nerds like Greg will always
talk about you know it's just a single
study let's wait and make sure it gets
replicated
and all that stuff right a single study
you don't want to get too carried away
this is a perfect example so in 1998
Gramm at all did a study and they tested
several different treatments it was a
placebo a caffeine capsule alone regular
coffee with caffeine in it just a normal
cup of coffee decaf coffee and then the
final treatment was decaf coffee with a
caffeine capsule okay all of the
treatments aside from the placebo
obviously and the decaf coffee provided
four point four five milligrams per
kilogram of caffeine it's a pretty
standard
arrghh agenda caffeine dose the only
group out of all of those that improved
was water plus a caffeine capsule so the
regular coffee didn't work in the decaf
with the caffeine capsule also didn't
work and so what they theorized was that
something in the coffee was inhibiting
the beneficial effects of caffeine and
they thought maybe it was the
chlorogenic acids but I mean with coffee
it's like take your pick there's like
hundreds of bioactive compounds in it we
essentially ran with that conclusion for
like 15 years to the to the point that
as late as like 2010 in review papers
they would say like yeah if you want to
get an organic affect it can't be from
coffee you got to get the good stuff the
caffeine anhydrous so this is like a
real-world example of where for I think
about 15 years we took this one study
and said well looks fine to me and just
went with it and then it wasn't really
until 2013 that a few studies started
reinvestigating that question and it
kind of just went the other direction
you know there's still we could
certainly use more data related to this
particular question but from what we
have in the last few years there have
been more studies coming out there's one
by Hodgson at all there's one by
Richardson and Clark my lab group did a
paper on the topic and generally
speaking what we find was some of this
more recent research is that caffeinated
coffee seems to be
fine in comparison to a caffeine
supplement which intuitively makes sense
but is actually a controversial take or
at least it was up until about a couple
years ago so this is a real-world world
example of when people like Greg want to
be a stick-in-the-mud
and they say hold your horses let's see
if that actually replicates this is an
example of that however I will note that
Pickering and girge ik in this paper
they bring up some good points there are
some challenges with coffee if you're
using coffee and trying to get our genic
doses of caffeine sometimes that
requires you to ingest a pretty high
volume of fluid so for some people that
might be annoying pre-workout having a
bunch of coffee obviously you can go to
some you know more concentrated coffee
type products with higher caffeine
content but another thing to keep in
mind is variability of caffeine content
so the type of being how it's roasted
how finely it's ground how it's prepared
all of these things go into the actual
caffeine content of the coffee you're
drinking so if you're trying to get an
exact orogenic dose for a really big
competition that's something to keep in
mind and a great example that is a study
by mckusker at all they got the same
product from a coffee shop six days in a
row so same product same location with
Starbucks right I believe so yeah and of
those six days the lowest caffeine
content of this product was 259
milligrams and the highest was 564 so
that's a hell of a range I mean that
those are two very different experiences
from that cup of coffee right so it's
something to keep in mind if you're
gonna use coffee as a regular orga Jenna
Cade I do you know I think it's fine but
if you're like let's say it's a day one
of the Olympic Trials I think you're
trying to make sure you've got your your
caffeine dose perfectly titrated then it
might make sense to go with something
else brand new study that is not super
relevant but I found it fascinating
like a week or two ago by Fukuda the
title is habitual coffee drinkers may
present condition responses from coffee
queue and this was a study in I believe
it was in the field of psychology this
isn't like a performance Fitness type
thing but I found it interesting the
sight and smell of coffee alone
they didn't ingest any of it they
basically were just like okay smell it
you see it here's some coffee
take it away that alone appeared to
enhance performance on a simple reaction
time task in habitual coffee drinkers so
is one of those things where if you
believe that your love for coffee has
gotten to the point where simply being
in its presence is a positive thing for
you apparently these people got a
benefit from just smelling and seeing it
all right and there was one more study
that I wanted to talk about so the title
of which is which specific modes of
exercise training are most effective for
treating low back pain Network
meta-analysis by Owen at all and so
essentially what this was doing is
looking to see what sort of
interventions and therapies helped with
various things associated with low back
pain and then also which therapies were
more or less effective so they looked at
things like what most helps with pain
what most improves physical function and
what most improves mental health because
people with chronic pain conditions
often find themselves in a pretty dark
mental place as well and so that's what
they were trying to do not just to see
if these things work but which things
work better than others and so as far as
pain goes Pilates actually was the
runaway number one so they they did some
statistics like based on the results of
the meta-analysis to see what the odds
were that each particular treatment was
the most effective and least effective
so I'm gonna go down and so like
that has to do with both the effect size
estimate and also the variability so for
example something if there's two
treatments and one has a slightly larger
effect size but it's a more highly
variable it may have a slightly lower mi
you may have slightly lower odds of
being the best treatment than something
with a slightly lower mean effect size
but much smaller variability so I'm
doing this by likelihood of something
being the best not just what had the
largest effect size so it it's kind of
like a dual measure of effect size and
consistency of the effect so as far as
pain goes Pilates seemed to be the
runaway number one most effective thing
it was like a 68% chance or so that it
was the best therapy of the ones
included in this meta-analysis other
ones that did quite well were aerobic
exercise and so that was number two and
then roughly tied for third were
stabilization exercises and resistance
exercise moving on to physical function
the most effective was resistance
training followed by stabilization
exercise and water based exercise
roughly tied for second place with yoga
in I guess fourth place because there
was a two-way tie for a second and then
aerobic exercise and Pilates were also
quite effective for physical function as
well and from a mental health
perspective the most effective seemed to
be resistance training followed closely
by aerobic training with Pilates in a
somewhat distant third so things just to
mention about this is the type of
exercise that most people would do like
when most people think oh I'm gonna go
work out
they're either thinking I'm gonna go
lift some weights or I'm gonna go for a
run like those seem to be the most
common types of like quote unquote
workouts that people do and aerobic
exercise and resistance exercise were
both among the most effective treatments
for pain
physical function and mental health so
you know if you're dealing with low back
pain and you're thinking should I go to
the gym and do some sort of gym thing
the answer is probably yes
Pilates also seemed to do quite well it
showed up on all three also so you know
I mean I'm biased I was about to say so
like if your mom or dad is dealing with
low back pain and they're like how
should I do Pilates say sure but I mean
if you're dealing with low back pain and
you're thinking should I do Pilates sure
like that's all that also seems to be a
very very good option but yeah so kind
of depending on what you're interested
in resistance training maybe is the most
robust it seems to improve both physical
function and mental health the most
Pilates seems to be much much more for
just like pain itself but really I would
say those three have the most support
but and I think this is the most
important thing just get moving so again
those were kind of ranked by odds of
being the best therapy of all of the
ones included in the meta-analysis but
you can pull up the full text of this
and look at the effect sizes the effect
sizes for all three of those outcomes
pain physical function and mental health
for virtually all of the exercise types
were large effects so we're talking
really anywhere between like the Cohen's
D of 0.7 which is like a moderate effect
but close to a large effect up to about
like 1.3 1.4 so like really meaty effect
sizes for all of the outcomes for all of
the various types of exercise so really
you can't go wrong it's you're you're
choosing it's like are you choosing the
best of a lot of good options it's not
like these are good options and the rest
are [ __ ] but so anything that got people
moving was great however all of the
controlled conditions weren't that good
so with low back pain or really any type
of pain generally it tends to improve
over time you're just dealing with
regret regression to the mean
but in terms of how the control
conditions worked either if it's a true
control a passive control which is like
you know just getting advice from a
physical therapist who doesn't actually
lay hands on you or and I think this is
the most important one hands-on control
conditions in these studies so that
would include stuff like manual therapy
or chiropractic which a lot of people do
go towards for treatment of low back
pain those things weren't nearly as
effective as any kind of exercise so
this is something that's pretty
important because a lot of times when
people are in pain they develop kanessa
phobia like they just stop moving
and I mean there are probably not
advisable ways to move if you're dealing
with low back pain like if you find that
say max triples on the deadlift tend to
aggravate your back and you're dealing
with low back pain you should get out
and move but maybe don't pull max
triples you know but kind of within
reason you get moving and that tends to
help things a lot stuff like manual
therapy and chiropractic maybe it's
better than nothing but that's not much
of an endorsement the the effect sizes
they're just massively paled in
comparison to any type of exercise so I
think that's the biggest takeaway you
know like maybe if the biggest issue
with your low back pain is just the pain
itself yeah go for Pilates maybe if you
know the biggest problems it's causing
you or decrements and physical function
or decrements and mental health yeah
maybe go for a resistance training but
for the most part just get moving and
that's gonna that's gonna make things
better and don't try to rely on just
manual therapy and chiropractic to fix
it it's probably not going to be nearly
as effective as exercise would be let me
ask you a quick follow-up for that you
mentioned that for all the exercise
interventions the effect sizes were
pretty pretty big or any of them
scientifically considered huge no they
weren't so giving you an actual answer
to a joke question
like I said they were all pretty much in
like the 0.72 1.4 range that's pretty
good
yeah for sure alright well I think that
does it for today's episode I believe
we've fatigued the audience we've
outstayed our welcome this is probably
time to wrap it up to play us out I do
want to remind the listeners that we
have our biggest sale of the year going
on the the big Black Friday sale for
mass is going on November 25th to
December 2nd and remember the huge
percentage of the proceeds of that sale
go to the American Foundation for
Suicide Prevention really really good
charity they get a hundred percent of
the profit from the new subscribers we
get during the sale along with 50% of
the profit from current subscribers so
it's a great time to get a good a good
price on a mass subscription and you can
feel good about knowing that a big
proportion of that is going to charity
so that does it for today's episode
we've got on the other side of the music
we've got an interview with Ben [ __ ]
we talked to him about power building
basically the diffusion of powerlifting
and bodybuilding for people who are in
who have both you know lofty physique
goals and lofty powerlifting goals we
also talked about physical culture a
little bit of a change of pace for for
our podcast but Ben did his PhD studying
physical culture and talks to us all
about specifically the history of
physical culture it's a really really
interesting conversation so we hope
you'll enjoy it as always thanks for
listening and we'll talk to you next
week
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast today we have a special treat we
are joined by Ben [ __ ] Ben thank you
so much for coming on the show thanks
for having me so Ben for any of our
listeners who are not already familiar
with you and your work do you mind
giving us a brief description of who you
are and what you do sure I Who am I I
guess that's a tough question but I am a
physical culture historian and
professional power lifter I guess you
could say I've kind of forged my own
path and you know currently what I do is
compete in both powerlifting and
bodybuilding now and I coached mathletes
I do a lot of social media writing and
other types of content and on the side I
also do some academic work related to
the history of physical culture which
encompasses not just strength sports but
really anything that people do to make
themselves more fit or more capable of
performing in athletic events or even in
their daily lives and you did your PhD
in in a physical culture program at the
University of Texas right correct or is
there any analogous program to that
whenever I think physical culture that's
the one that comes to mind are there
other programs like it across the
country there are but they're pretty few
and far between it's a rather niche
program as you can imagine and the
selection of schools that you have to
study that sort of thing is rather
limited are are you still doing your
research at Texas or have you branched
out on your own at this point I branched
out on my own I my fiance and I recently
moved to Virginia actually it's been a
full year now and so I'm no longer at
Texas at all though I do hope to return
at one point yeah and so been on the
powerlifting side of things it seems
like you write a lot for elite FTS is
that right yeah I write for actually a
lot of sites elite FTS barb and I also
write for I've done a little a little
bit of stuff for Kabuki strength some
other you know
off stuff I think garage gym I did
something for and similar sites like
that so I really enjoy the writing
process and I've been pretty prolific in
that area awesome so I would imagine a
lot of our listeners have read your your
writing before and if they haven't
hopefully they'll check it out after
this episode so today obviously because
of your background we certainly want to
talk a lot about physical culture
because you have a very unique
perspective on that and given how much
you have studied it but before we do
that you mentioned that you compete in
both powerlifting and bodybuilding so
you're one of those few people that
really embraces that hybrid position
where you do a little bit of both do you
see yourself as basically 50/50 or are
you more of a power lifter or more of a
bodybuilder yeah not even close to 50/50
it's more like 90 10 I I don't really
enjoy bodybuilding at all but I do you
know seem to be able to stay lean fairly
easily and over the course of my
Paralympic career I've added enough
muscle mass that I can do decently and
embody building with a little bit of
work for the areas that are neglected
with typical powerlifting training but
you know is really the the reason I
stepped into bodybuilding in the first
place was to give my body a break from
you know the strain of the heavy weights
my body in my mind so the first time you
dieded were you surprised by how much it
sucks getting like stage lean not to
like the last three weeks I'm honestly I
think I over dieded for that point I
think you know had I stopped three weeks
out and just started maintaining I could
have looked a lot better on stage yeah
I've definitely been there it's the
thing is if you're a relatively intense
person or a very focused person it's so
easy to fall into that if like well I'm
already here I might as well just push
and push and push given that you do a
little bit of both you've got some power
lifting and some bodybuilding how do you
generally set up a power building
program I mean I would imagine just
because of what you've accomplished on
both sides of that spectrum a lot of
people come to you saying I want to do
the same thing I want to have a strong
squat bench and deadlift but I also want
to look like a bodybuilder how do you
begin putting together a program like
for somebody you're right I do get a lot
of people asking that question and it's
really challenging for me because you
know I spent probably the first god I
started training 2000 2005 maybe 2001
and so for the first decade of training
I was only focused on the squat bench
and deadlift and added a lot of strength
of those movements so then when it comes
time to add in the accessory work that's
gonna build up the points that don't get
a lot of work from those which are
typically you know stuff like these from
these calves arm shoulders that sort of
thing you can add it in without really
interfering with your training because
you've already built that solid base but
I get so many people asking you know
they just want to jump in without having
that base and it's virtually impossible
and so I really really push them hard to
just focus on powerlifting until they
have a sufficient level of strength to
really support the muscle mass that they
need in order to reach those goals
you know when I'm programming for myself
it's much different again because I
don't need a lot of work for muscles
that for the bigger muscles right a lot
of hypertrophy focus work so I can
afford to build my program around the
main lifts and variations in the main
lifts and then I'll add in you know
currently have a couple extra days for
my shoulders and arms we're fairly I'm
good most leave and work sets of you
know 50 or 100 reps just trying to get
some blood through that muscle to really
focus on building the muscle volume but
not really concerned about strength at
all so you basically kind of view it in
stages where where you bring somebody in
who has both these goals and you say
well well let's just kind of focus on
the powerlifting side for a while and
build a base in the product in the
process and then we'll start working on
refining some of the details associated
with bodybuilding absolutely absolutely
it's really really hard to convince
people that really hard but I very
strongly believe that so I mean about
how long of a buy-in do you do you
typically ask of people because because
I could imagine people are quite
impatient with that yeah and it really
depends on the individual you know
because some people do have a very good
strength base built already and then you
know maybe you need a couple months of
polishing up technique other people who
are raw beginners might need five years
of focusing purely on training
until they have that base built so it's
extraordinarily individual it's almost
completely individual but at the same
time you know typically what I tell
people is okay give the strength in
three months because I think three
months is kind of the minimum you need
to see you need to put in two in order
to see decent strength gains and a lot
of times what happens is people start
training that way but fine it's really
enjoyable they finally they're seeing
progress almost on a day-to-day basis
and they'll kind of it'll be easier to
convince them okay let's stick on this
route for a little bit longer yeah that
makes sense
I'm just curious here do you know of of
many other people who've kind of taken
the same route through powerlifting and
then bodybuilding that you have because
just right off the top of my head I can
think of several people who were like
fairly successful bodybuilders or at
least like you know did hypertrophy
focused training for a long time got
super jacked and then tried to
transition to powerlifting and did quite
well but I I can't think of that many
people right off the top of my head who
you know started on the powerlifting
side of things and then went on to be
successful in bodybuilding that very
well is probably just blindness on my
part because I don't follow bodybuilding
that closely so like when someone slips
out of powerlifting and gets into the
bodybuilding world they just kind of
fall off my radar but can you think of
any other people just right off the top
of my head who have been successful
taking the same route you have I mean it
really depends on what you mean by
powerlifting people love to claim that
you know Ronnie Coleman was the ultimate
power builder because he did a few
powerlifting means but that was never
really his you know main focus right and
so it's really hard to say okay how many
elite power lifters have done this and
also top of my head I don't know a whole
lot I think honestly I think if you're
gonna train to be that high of a level
of power lifter it can be you know at
least for me it was pretty mentally
exhausting thinking okay now I
essentially have to start from scratch
learning an entirely new sport where
yeah maybe I have a little bit of leg up
from the 15 plus years I put into this
but it's a little bit compared to these
other guys who you know whether they've
just been
genetically gifted or they've been
training him different style for longer
or whatever the case may be you know
they're way ahead of me relatively now
that that makes a ton of sense so you
think it's more there aren't that many
people who've been successful going the
direction you have mostly just for for
psychological reasons more so than like
physical reasons yeah and I don't have a
lot of data to support that but that's
kind of my opinion from some of the
people that I've talked to and from my
own experience and again I think you
mentioned this but the other way around
it's much different you know you start
off with bodybuilding I think picking up
powerlifting is maybe a little bit
easier but I haven't had that
perspective so I can't say for sure no I
I got you that that makes that makes a
ton of sense I just hadn't really heard
that perspective before but I mean now
that you explain it it makes all the
sense in the world
I wonder if you guys know Johnny Jackson
used to train with branch Warren a lot
did he start in powerlifting cuz I know
he used to hit the big three pretty hard
I I believe he did
I'm not sure though yeah I'm not really
sure either um I think his best deadlift
was something like 800 which is a great
deadlift but at 275 again that's not
really elite level so oh yeah yeah
definitely definitely
so you've competed in both it's not just
like hey I'd like to be kind of good at
both I mean you've competed in
powerlifting competed in bodybuilding
and so as you approach one competition
you know whether it's a powerlifting one
or a bodybuilding one do you start to
shift your training to be basically just
pure powerlifting or pure bodybuilding
or do you continue to train as if it's
kind of a hybrid thing even won
competitions approach it depends on how
close you are to the competition I think
you know for powerlifting is definitely
beneficial to keep some of the I but the
some of the higher rep work and I want
to say hypertrophy focus work to some of
the higher rep work and even in the
later stages of prep because it's very
important to focus on that balance you
know for me if I'm not training my outer
quads well I know my knees are gonna
start hurting because I have a tendency
I flat feet and I have a tendency to let
my VMO take over and so if I'm not
specifically addressing that much
grupe well it's gonna it's gonna lead to
problems the opposite is also true I
think you know I think a body building
if you're dropping all of your heavy
movements as soon as you start prep I
think you're probably gonna lose too
much size dieting again I don't have
nearly as much experience in the
bodybuilding world and I can't say that
for sure but that was kind of my
impression I wish that I had trained a
little bit heavier during prep and not
dieted so hard to be honest with you but
again in the very late stages of either
you know say you're three to four weeks
out of a meet or a show I do think you
have to focus exclusively on one or the
other yeah I mean at a certain point you
there's just that need for
specialization you know in that you know
that last month maybe six weeks leading
in now one of the interesting things
about people who do both bodybuilding
and powerlifting in full disclosure I
have competed in both but I was a
bodybuilder who did powerlifting to stay
busy
basically so kind of be inverse of of
your perspective but lately in the field
of exercise science there's been there's
been a couple kind of like opinion
papers out that have argued that
essentially the change in muscle mass
over one's lifting career is not
correlated with the change in strength
over that career or more specifically
over the context of maybe a study you
know a few months of training that the
change in muscle size is not related to
the change in strength as someone who
has you know been involved with both
hypertrophy training and powerlifting
well what's your take on that general
concept you know I'm probably gonna
defer to this answer quite a bit
throughout the interview but I think
it's entirely individual personally and
I hope you guys don't take offense to
this but even coming from an academic
background I put almost the zero weight
on academic studies because I know how
sloppily designed how poorly executed
and how limited
their applications can be in the real
world and so I it really kills me when
somebody you know says that something
doesn't work because they've read a
paper that said the contrary and in this
case you know you mentioned within the
scope of a study you know it didn't make
a big difference but if you have a guy
who's training for three months he's not
gonna make that much progress no matter
what compared to a guy who's been
trained in thirty years and so I do
think there are certainly individuals
who you know can add a ton of muscle
mass without ever training heavy and the
opposite is true too right you can add a
ton of strength without ever adding a
lot of muscle but I think for the vast
majority of people they're gonna be
pretty correlated yeah I mean that
that's the thing that kills me as well
like strength can change pretty
substantially in a few months especially
if you're working with untrained lifters
but like muscle size even even if you're
dealing with completely untrained folks
like there may be some some visual
changes in how much muscle someone has
on their frame but if you're talking
like you know how many actual
millimeters of quad thickness did they
add it's not that much so you're
essentially dealing with really small
changes that have a a reasonably
substantial degree of measurement error
and you're looking to see like does this
do these small changes in a noisy
measurement correlate with something
else and I don't think it should shock
anyone that sometimes the correlation is
relatively poor like just knowing the
measurements and the magnitude of
changes you're dealing with it's
shocking that the correlations are even
weaker than they are you know yes
absolutely I totally agree yeah I mean
you know I come from that world of
carrying out you know exercise and
nutrition studies and in controlled lab
lab environments and you know if I do a
study and the results conflict with what
we observe day in and day out in the
real world my first question is
basically what's wrong with our
measurement or our design it's not well
clearly the whole world
means crumbling but this study captured
the real truth you know what I mean I
feel like that's one of those things
where if you have a particular study
design or research paradigm that doesn't
seem to be reflecting what everyone is
observing in the trenches it's probably
more important to reflect about what
might be flawed in the paradigm rather
than is it possible that everything I
thought I understood about muscle and
strength was wrong so it's kind of that
that same thing that you said of like
there's a lot of these studies with with
severe limitations that people often
take it in isolation and treat it as an
undeniable fact when in reality there's
there's quite a bit of nuance to to suss
out with any particular study or or even
collection of studies now let's let's
bring it back to the trenches one of the
things I thought was cool when I first
started messing around with powerlifting
after doing years of bodybuilding was
powerlifting taught me a little bit that
I could take back to my bodybuilding
training in the future I thought
powerlifting in a wave made me a better
bodybuilder what do you think is
something that most bodybuilders would
benefit from adopting when it comes to
how power lifters train I think the
level of effort that you're putting into
the training is far far far greater in
powerlifting I really do even having
gone through a pretty intense prep you
know it's hard to push yourself when
you're dieting very very hard and in
those cases I can see you know the
chances of injure go up your fatigue
levels so high sure you're not going to
Train all out that but I see up almost
every bodybuilder in my gym they train
like that year-round and I think when
you're in the offseason and you're
rested and you're fresh and again plenty
calories and if you're not training
heavy you're doing yourself a major to
service a major to service and most
bodybuilders you know think they can
train the same year-round and make
progress and maybe they can make
progress but I think they would make far
greater progress if they actually
learned how to train hard and heavy when
appropriate going harder going heavier
now now what about the inverse do you
think there's anything that power
lifters can stand to gain
if it borrowing some concepts or some
lessons from from body builder training
yeah it's almost it's almost exactly the
same but you know sometimes you'll have
power lifters you start dieting when
they know they need to make weight for a
show and they just eat like total crap
the rest of the year and it's just like
why it doesn't make sense to me you're
giving up so much potential recovery you
know health benefits muscular what sorry
I got I'm kind of uh fired up now so my
my words aren't coming to me but your
body composition could be so much better
and all it takes is you know not eating
junk it day in and day out but I think a
lot of power lifters think oh well you
know I don't have to look pretty and so
they almost used it as an excuse to eat
like crap so so basically body builders
should be training more like power
lifters and power lifters should be
eating more like body builders that's my
if I had to pick two you know
overarching theme so it would definitely
be the case
those would definitely be the two ones
now obviously you can give know a lot of
nuance here I mean for example uh you
know if you're saying okay you gotta
train hard and heavy if you're a
bodybuilder in the offseason well maybe
but maybe you're not gonna benefit that
much from doing heavy squats or heavy
deadlifts depending on what the case may
be you know what your goals are what
your strength levels are how your body
responds and you know maybe you're a
power lifter who you know focus does eat
clean but you know you focus only on a
squat bench deadlift and you would
really be benefited by doing some
isolation work for certain muscle groups
I mentioned my outer quads and how much
I've benefited just from training those
which was shocking to me but the ability
to activate those muscle groups has
really made a big difference in my
compound lives so this is very out of
left field but I'm genuinely curious
what uh what you do to specifically
train your outer quads so as someone who
doesn't have flat feet I kind of feel
like if I do quad work it just trains
all of my quads kind of similarly and
I've heard about people too I've heard
people talk about isolating certain
heads of their quads certain ways and I
feel like I've tried ever
and everything just feels like just
normal quad work so I I'm curious what
you do to target your outer quads so for
me it's mostly dealing with foot
position and I like to use machine so
that I can really focus on the movement
all right I'm just kidding excuse me on
the muscle I'm out of the movement
because if I'm doing squats I can keep
that in my head and I can get a little
bit in there but it's pretty hard cuz
you got to focus on stabilizing the
weight moving the weight whereas if I'm
on a leg press well it's like I can use
a super controlled negative and I can
make sure that I'm keeping my foot
position perfect where I've got my feet
pretty wide for me right and if you've
seen me squat you know I swap pretty
darn narrow so pretty wide for me I've
also got my toes pointed pretty far in
and I'm really trying to spread the
platform which again you know those are
typical cues that you would use in a
squat but for me those really left a lot
out because you know I honestly think is
the flat foot maybe the weak abductors
and that led to knee pain for me for
that kept me out of the US Open last
year so for me that's what works again
so I'm such a big proponent of
individuality in both sports that I
hesitate to make any blanket
recommendations for me it's much easier
to work with somebody in person so I can
see what their movement patterns look
like and how they might need to change
those to target different muscle groups
know that that makes a lot of sense I I
mean I I wasn't looking for like a
general recommendation for vielle
training I was just genuinely curious
because that's not something I've ever
personally experienced so just building
off those prior two questions that Trek
that Trek's asked you know what power
lifters could learn from body builders
and what body builders could learn from
power lifters as someone with kind of a
foot in both communities what are some
just general misconceptions you see on
both sides of the aisle like what are
things that you see a lot of
bodybuilders believing about power
lifters that just aren't true and
conversely what are some misconceptions
that power lifters have about body
builders well you know for the biggest
misconception I had about body builders
before I started competing
was that they were all kind of I hate to
use this word but prima donnas I guess
we type where you know there's a lot of
rivalry and they're not there's no real
sense community and it's everybody wants
to one-up the other guy and at my
experience that both shows that I did
completely untrue everyone was super
supportive everybody is kind of in the
same boat suffering together and so
there's a lot a lot of support that you
get from the community and bodybuilding
it's really really awesome so that was
my personal biggest misconception the
other was that bodybuilding is pretty
easy and I do think in offseason if you
train like a typical bodybuilder it's
pretty darn easy but I think if you
train hard and you diet hard when you're
dieting bodybuilding is pretty darn hard
just as hard as powerlifting from the
flip side it's you know it's really hard
for me to to say because I started out
as a part of the through my background
is entirely in strength and so I just
don't have the perspective if I had to
guess it'd be that all power lifters are
fat and you know nowadays you know
that's not true there's a lot more
competition in the lower weight classes
I mean you can look at Yuri Belkin who
you know as we're recording this he's
gonna become compete in the big dogs
tomorrow against some of the hugest guys
and your is relatively slim for for
somebody putting up those types of
numbers I feel like Yuri is just
trolling everyone like dude goes to 42
at every meet in ways like 224 like what
the [ __ ] Yuri just cut to 220 stop
making everyone else feel bad I've heard
he moved all the way up to like 228 to
this oh [ __ ] he's bullying hard yeah
Jesus Christ he's a monster
yes all right Ben so we picked your
brain about training a little bit now we
want to talk to you about the other
aspect here which is the physical
culture so we mentioned earlier that you
did your PhD studying physical culture
so I guess the first question is why
pursue physical culture as an academic
pursuit why is that important to you
actually if I could interject just
something more basic than that I feel
like physical culture isn't a term
that's used as often as it used to be so
just just so all of the listeners are on
the same page here how would you define
physical culture first off um so
personally when I define physical
culture I tell people exercise that's
kind of uh not a great definition by any
means if you were to get an academic
definition you know I believe don't
quote me on this but I believe what my
adviser and her husband Janna Terry Todd
came up with was that physical cultures
any sort of purposeful activity that
people do to improve their lives or
their academic performance and I think
the important thing to remember there is
purposeful right it's not walking the
dog it's something that you're doing
specifically to make yourself more fit
to feel better in your daily life or to
perform better or your chosen sport but
it's also separate from sport right so
it's not you know basketball wouldn't be
considered physical culture that gets
kind of tricky when you then talk about
well as powerlifting a sport is
bodybuilding a sport because those
generally do fall under the umbrella
physical culture and when you get in
academia the arguments about definitions
of certain terms can go on and on and on
and I don't like to get into that sort
of nuance but that that would be my best
kind of summary at a high level make
sense to me yeah and now that we've got
a working definition what why pursue it
as an academic pursuit why is it
important to you I'm really fell into a
man so I was I was working at Google
when I applied to go to school Texas and
I got my undergrad degree and finance
and information technology from the
University of Virginia and I worked for
a few years and finally landed this job
at Google and I'd always wanted to work
there because I'm a bit of a nerd I you
know you see all the the you read the
articles and you see the movies and you
think it's just this dream place to work
so I get there and I find out I'm not
all that happy there and I need to you
know need a change of pace and so I had
always plan to go to business school and
so I was looking at different programs
and the universe and you know I was
training at the time I started training
in high school for wrestling and so the
sport was a passion of mine I thought
you know maybe I could combine
these things get into sport in some way
but still use the management skills that
I had from my my undergrad degree and
hopefully from my MBA and so Texas has a
very good kinesiology program in general
including their MBA with a focus on
sports studies and so while I was
browsing the Texas website I found my
future advisors biography Jan Todd and
if you guys don't know about her she was
the world's strongest woman she was one
of the very first female power lifters
ever she has hundreds and hundreds of
accolades and fitness she runs the
Arnold strongman classic every year in
March in Ohio and so she's very very
active in the industry and I found her
biography I was like wow I want to work
with this person so I call her up and I
tell her hey you know I'm applying the
MBA program as hoping if I get in that I
can do some research with you on the
side
well Jane has very strong personality
and so Jen basically said you know
forget the MBA just come with from me
beyond me at first no I had this plan
and she just slowly cooks me along the
way she was like well you know why don't
you submit your resume just so we
haven't file in case you change your
mind so I do that she was like well you
know why don't you take the GRE just so
we have your scores in case I'm sure
it's no big deal it doesn't cost much
and so I do that and she's like well you
know I think we could probably get some
scholarships for fun
and so she just kind of you know pushes
gently gently gently until finally I buy
in and once I do I realize it's
absolutely the right fit for me because
it's really doing what I love not what
you know I thought I was gonna make
money at or thought you know I was
supposed to do that sort of thing so
just out of curiosity if you you know if
you weren't then Pollock and a
world-class power lifter and Instagram
famous and a prolific writer how does
one how does one apply a physical
culture degree just out of curiosity you
teach other people to study physical
culture so now that we kind of have the
groundwork laid why study physical
culture what is it in the first place
kind of going all the way back
what are some of the roots of physical
culture in the West which is probably
what would apply to most of the people
listening to this and then what are some
like major physical culture traditions
elsewhere in the world that are you know
maybe really cool but most listeners
wouldn't be aware of so the first and
they answer the first question I think
is pretty cool because the roots of
physical culture in the West are very
deeply tied to religion and so actually
if you trace the trace the history of it
in America at least you know there was a
strong tradition of purity ISM right
when the country was founded or right
when the first settlers came over and in
the Puritan culture you know the body
was considered almost ungodly because if
you were too concerned about your
outward appearance you weren't focused
enough on your spiritual life or at
least that's you know how their logic
went well sometime in the mid eighteen
hundreds there came a new movement
called muscular Christianity and this
actually started over in Europe but the
idea was that you know actually we have
it backwards God gave you this body and
if you're really trying to worship God
to the utmost you're gonna do as much
and take care of your body as much as
you possibly can and so this idea of
muscular Christianity really led to
people well led to males at least
focusing more on different aspects of
sport and different aspects of improving
their bodies as a way of kind of showing
their religious spirit and so if you're
really really tracing the roots back
that's that's where it all kind of
starts and that's obviously a very very
rough rough sketch and I would never
explain it like that in an academic talk
but I think that if you're trying to get
the broad Overby that's really more or
less how it how it started and then from
there you know you can get a lot into
how technology and media influence its
growth and if I were to pick two you
know umbrella areas those would be the
ones that really brought the school
culture into the mainstream so do you
see that as like the foundation of
modern physical culture in a way that's
like discontinuous with say ancient
Greece like do you think that there was
kind of
a split such that it would be improper
to trace the roots you know all the way
back into the BC era
yeah it's it's it's contentious right I
mean there are obviously a lot of
traditions that began with the ancient
Greeks and Romans but you know still our
practice today and then there's a lot
that's not I mean the Olympics is the
obvious example right but then you had
art divided between the ancient Olympics
and the modern Olympics which began in
1896 and/or 1892 actually think and so
it's it's it's difficult again academics
really love to argue these nuances and I
am adjust the nuances don't interest me
so I might not be the best person to ask
from that perspective but yeah I I
personally would would look at it more
as an outgrowth at that muscular
Christianity movement and then changes
in technology and technology in the
media around the turn of the century for
me there those are kind of more relevant
factors well I mean you're the only
person with any academic qualifications
in the history of physical culture on
this podcast right now so regardless of
what the other people say in the context
of this podcast anything you say on the
subject I'm perfectly fine just taking
your word for it that's one of the nice
things about studying a really niche
topic is that you know unless you're
going to a conference about that topic
you're probably the only one who has any
idea of what you're talking about yeah I
mean that that makes sense I I should
have thought of that yeah so quick
follow-up question for me Ben you had
mentioned that the muscular Christianity
movement was pretty much exclusively
male what was the when did the tide turn
and when did women kind of enter the
fray in terms of physical culture in the
West well you can certainly find
examples of females who trained under
what would be called physical culture
practices in as early as early as the
late
19th century but I think you know you
look at modern women sport and it's far
far different than when the sport was at
that time and I'm honestly not an expert
in that area and so I'm really hesitant
to make that make any claims along that
but the number of you got to remember
that even even when this muscular
Christianity movement was more on the
people who trained exclusively for the
definition of physical culture that I
gave earlier it was it was pretty niche
and women were even more rare in that
arena you know you look at early chips
you look at gems dating all the way back
to the mid 20th century and oftentimes
when there weren't even allowed in them
and so you know there's obviously a lot
of issues regarding gender inequality
that go into that and and other societal
factors that take it much much more
broad than physical culture itself all
right so just kind of looping back to
the second part of my question so that's
the roots of fiscal culture in the West
what other physical culture traditions
are there out there or have there been
out there that you know our listeners in
the US Canada Europe might not be aware
of uh there's a lot there's a whole lot
I think the most important one to call
out would kind of be the Jenner Turner
movement the German Turner movement is I
was also very influential in the growth
of his culture in the West and that was
essentially if I were to draw a poor
analogy it would be something like you
know talk p90x or other popular exercise
program that was focused mainly on
gymnastics calisthenics that sort of
resistive extra that sort of exercise
that wasn't strictly using resistance
although they did occasionally use like
dumbbells and things like that but that
was a big practice that was brought over
to the United States and largely
remained in German immigrant communities
and became integrated into larger
physical cultural practices and that was
pretty important in the evolution of
physical culture itself in America
other practices I think are cool you
know you can and actually Jan and and
rokh I've done some some really cool
videos on these but you can look at the
stone lifting that was done in some of
the Icelandic countries and some some
areas of Spain you can look at the
wrestling that was done in India and
other areas in the East and oh boy
there's there's actually there's a whole
whole lot of different things that you
can go into you know the history of yoga
is very fascinating all those sorts of
things to me are really really cool but
it gets so broad because physical
culture itself is such a broad topic
that you could spend years studying any
one of these and then you did spend
years studying one particular topic or
at least you you obviously anyone doing
a PhD selects a topic for a dissertation
project and you did yours on Jack
LaLanne right yeah chuckling so why him
so originally well yeah originally my
focus was specifically on physical
culture and entrepreneurship in the 20th
century and 20th century in America so I
was looking at guys who practice
physical culture on their own and really
turned that into a business for
themselves or for their clients or for
other people or for whatever and
originally my plan for the dissertation
was to do a study on the spread of
unique gymnasiums throughout the country
because if you look at that spread it's
really really really really interesting
it begins on the East Coast obviously
because that's where you know most of
the early settlers were in the history
of the country but then moves over to
the west coast to California and then
spreads following post-world War two
where many of the soldiers who were
stationed in the West then went back to
their homes and were able to tell other
people about the gyms they trained at
California so the geographic spread is
really really interesting but right when
I was about to begin my dissertation Jan
was approached by Jacqueline's Widow
Elaine Elaine who wanted to make a
donation of some
information objects letters and research
and that sort of thing to the Start
Center and there was a whole whole whole
lot of information we're talking boxes
and boxes boxes of letters of newspaper
clippings of different promotional and
business-related materials so just a
wealth of information that was all going
to be available to start Center and Jack
in particular was an extraordinarily
influential figure in both the history
of fitness in America and also in the
history of you know Fitness
entrepreneurship and fitness celebrity
and so it was really a very natural
topic it was a pretty impactful topic
that would reach a broader audience than
my my planned study and so that's why I
decided to go with it it was really
lucky yeah I'm I'm glad you brought up
Fitness celebrity because I feel like a
lot of people today have never even
heard of Jack LaLanne actually first I
just like to comment that Elaine LaLanne
is like Bob Loblaw levels of the
legendary naming but yeah so my
grandmother was a huge Jack LaLanne fan
like had pictures of him clipped out
from magazines talked about the glory
days when he had as I understand it a
nationally syndicated TV show so like
how did he get that famous and like like
obviously there's big jack people who
have also gotten famous and are still
famous for example Arnold Schwarzenegger
but as I understand it Jack LaLanne had
a TV program where he told people about
working out and like did workouts and a
bunch of people tuned in so like how did
that happen and why do you think that
hasn't been replicated because to a very
large extent he was lucky he was in the
right place at the right time
god it's difficult for Nia when the TV
industry began so if you look at the
history of television specifically it
started out well you know the television
was invented much earlier but really
people the growth of television access
exploded
to exploded just astronomical rates and
so all of a sudden there was this need
for programming right because you had
gone from almost nobody has TB to
virtually everyone has a TV in the span
of a decade and so you need programming
to fill all that time and so they were
looking for different types of shows and
Jack did have a certain charisma that he
could really project and make himself
very affable to to viewers even without
ever interacting with them one on one or
in person and that certainly helped him
out a lot but just the fact that Elaine
had a history of radio broadcasting so
she was already hooked into that kind of
culture and the fact that he was in
California where you know Los Angeles in
particular was the hotbed of television
programming at the time and so he had
the he had this specific knowledge right
because again physical culture still a
niche thing it's growing very quickly
because all the soldiers who have been
in World War two were telling you know
their friends and their family back home
about all these cool things they saw
when they were stationed in California
you know there's a reason we we look at
Muscle Beach in California and see that
is you know the birthplace of
bodybuilding you know it's really not
and so he had knowledge about this topic
he had a very pleasant way of conveying
it to to viewers that people wanted to
watch and then he was in the right place
at the right time and so you know
putting all those three together is very
very difficult to plan it's not
something that you can you know really
say oh you know I'm gonna be the first
person to start a TV show about fitness
if there's already 100 different ones of
them and then on the same token you know
if they're none at all coming up with
that idea is not something that a lot of
people are gonna do so that was that
confluence of factors really helped him
I got you so I actually have at least
one more question on Jack LaLanne but I
want to pull out one of the things you
just said because I found it interesting
you said that a lot of people think
Muscle Beach is kind of the the home of
bodybuilding where it got started but
that's not the case so I was laboring
under the assumption here that that was
in fact true so
we're actually is like the birthplace of
bodybuilding and how did it then like
migrate to Muscle Beach and why do
people think that Muscle Beach is where
it all got started so I think actually
this is one area where most does
agriculture academics would agree that
bodybuilding started with Eugene Sandow
okay well performing strongman but also
had an incredible physique and you would
travel through different circuses and
give demonstrations of strength but also
show off his body and that really
inspired them Badar McFadden II saw him
at the World's Fair in Chicago started
inspired Bernard McFadden to write a
magazine about physical culture and
actually develop a publishing Empire
from it and you know sponsor actual
bodybuilding competitions although they
were very different than the
bodybuilding competitions we see today
so that's really where it started I
think the reason that so many people
associated with Muscle Beach is again
because of the media industry and not
television it's time but the movies and
so if you're gonna trace that back to
you you know there's actually an author
who calls the 1940s the age of the chest
because that was the time when you first
saw men not fully clothed in the movies
and you know one something several the
actors who were very popular at the time
had really well developed pecs and that
was seen as very attractive and then
when you have the all the bodybuilders
that come to Muscle Beach to train there
you know whether it's because the bore
whether it's because of other factors
those things compound the the situation
or the the growth rather and so then you
start seeing these bodybuilders starring
in movies like Steve Reeves and Hercules
and and that really captures the
mainstream attention wears against and
out and mcfadden were even though they
were very very prolific they still
weren't I wouldn't at least consider the
mainstream I got you so if I can kind of
go down this rabbit hole a little bit
further before looping back to Jack
LaLanne another thing you just mentioned
is that the early bodybuilding
competitions were you know much
different than what we see now what were
they like you know they would first of
all the level of leanness was nowhere
near what it is today the level
clarity was nowhere near where it was
today there was a greater focus I think
on muscular control imposing in fluidity
and there were also athletic components
of it there were often times where you
would have to perform certain lifts or
that sort of thing and then funnily the
judging was not exactly uh not exactly
well even today the judging is almost
completely subjective but I would say it
was even more so than I gotcha so kind
of looping back to Jack LaLanne one of
the one of the things we get asked about
a lot is to like talk more about how how
Fitness evolves and how lifting should
change and just kind of what people
should expect with the aging process if
they try to stay strong and active I'm
not a hundred percent sure about the
demographics of our podcast audience but
I know that our website audience you
know skews older than the average
Fitness site so a lot of people ask us
about that and one of the things I know
about Jack is he maintained incredible
physical shape as he got older and one
of the things he was kind of famous for
was performing feats of athletic prowess
when he turned like 60 65 70 years old
and I don't remember the details of any
of them do you know some of those just
right off the top of your head to kind
of maybe dazzle our our middle-aged and
older listeners
I think his most popular one was the
Escape from Alcatraz right where he's on
Alcatraz Island handcuffed and he swims
back to the mainland a handcuff the
entire way and you know it wasn't really
an escape such as he didn't break out of
the jail but to make that swim it is
treacherous water in and that the
currents are very very strong and on top
of that it's freezing cold you know so
to perform that feat was was pretty darn
impressive let let alone your swimming
handcuffed and it's over a mile
I believe that the total length was
something like 1.4 miles when you're
accounted for the for the current so
that was pretty pretty ridiculous the
other one that was really popular was
telling boats again handcuffed and
swimming all right he chose swimming in
particular because he had hurt his knee
playing football in high school and so
he was unable to run and so swing was
something that was you know kind of an
endurance sport that could also show off
his strength when he was talking to both
or whatever and so and it was something
so outlandish that it really caught
mainstream media attention do you
remember just right off the top of your
head how old he was when he did each of
those things he actually did most of
them twice he did them both and it was
almost always to celebrate a birthday he
claimed it was sometimes he didn't after
I was always on his birthday but he
started out in his 40s and before most
of the stunts and then repeated them in
the 60s to show that he had maintained
that level fitness that's so cool
I've got a follow-up question about Jack
because so Greg you mentioned that your
grandmother I think was a big fan and my
grandfather was as well and the question
I have is did he have went when he was
you know at his peak popularity with a
TV show and everything else did he have
rivals or peers that were anywhere on
like a similar tier or was he just kind
of a essentially a one-man fitness
industry he absolutely did you know I'm
one that I've written quite extensively
about his Debbie Drake who is obviously
a woman but her show was extraordinarily
popular mainly because she would perform
the exercises and what was then
considered pretty provocative clothing
and so she would have the women watching
because the women wanted to look like
her and she was she would have the men
watching because the men wanted to watch
a woman dressed like that contorting
herself on the floor so she was very
very popular then later when you get in
the 1980s and remember Jack's show was
syndicated so it's still being broadcast
then you have people like Jane Fonda so
you can really the he was by no means
the only person
space there were a lot of other people
as well who were lesser who were not as
well known and who also practiced
different forms of physical culture so
for example uh yoga was one that had
several TV shows about you know how to
perform yoga and introduce yoga to a
Western audience and there were some
some shows with military background
actually her roots in the military where
they would show calisthenics that were
performed by the military further for
general fitness in the 1950s national
fitness became kind of a bigger
mainstream concern not only because I
mean it meet it because but because of
the whole Cold War and there was the
idea that we had to be fit as a nation
to fight communism and so there were
several there's several opportunities
for other people to enter that space
what uh what current country do you
think we should start another cold war
with to get people interested in
physical culture and getting jacked
again just out of curiosity uh if you
had to orchestrate a geopolitical
conflict who you got it would absolutely
be Russia again I want to see a battle
of the giant plates and see how thick we
can get our dead with plates how much we
can make that bar Bend because you know
you look at the XI what is it the WRP
see and how they used the thicker plates
and the in their championships and I
would love to see that over I think
that's a good call I mean we beat them
once we can do it again absolutely I
wouldn't discount in the Netherlands
though I feel like they're a good off I
would like to jump in here and just say
that I will have the opportunity to go
to the Netherlands next year I'm gonna
meet my coach Mike Teixeira and I'm
gonna be giving a talk at the National
Museum for photography there about
powerlifting and bodybuilding how they
kind of relate to the media so I'm
pretty excited about that I was actually
going to ask you about that because I
saw that on your Instagram and I was
just just going to kind of put it out
there to ask if maybe I could give you
an undefined substance to attempt to
slow
than their water supply surreptitiously
but we can talk about that once we're
done recording
okay so is is there anything else that
you think is really really cool about
Jack LaLanne that most people don't know
that they should know um what the
coolest thing I always thought was how
he he trained for his swims or for his
mental strength you know I think a lot
of those feats and endurance that he did
were more mentally demanding than
physically demanding in some ways and so
the the extremes that he went to
practice for them like he would sit in a
bathtub and just have a lame pour ice
over him again and again again just sit
there for hours so that the cold
wouldn't bother him things like that to
me where were the most impressive by far
that makes sense so Ben you mentioned
some pretty incredible feats athletic
feats that Jack accomplished but
obviously you've got a very deep
understanding of the history of physical
culture do you have like a favorite
lifter or a favorite lifting achievement
that most people have never heard about
um you know I'm not really sure it's
hard for me to say because it's hard for
me to have perspective on what lifting
was like back in those times but if I
had to pick one I think Bob people's who
was the first person to pull a 700 pound
deadlift at 181 I think that was a
really really cool story he was trained
by my advisors husband Terry Todd and he
actually had a very unique style of
deadlifting where he would deadlift with
a very very rounded back and was still
able to lock out enormous amounts of
weights and Terry also trained Lamar
Gant who had scoliosis bad scoliosis and
pulled the same way and Terry still
claimed until his death that Omar game
was the most impressive lifter of all
time for the feats that he was able to
perform at such low low body weights so
those guys were definitely definitely be
up there is it controversial to suggest
that Lamar Gant is the best power lifter
of all time I think that it probably is
and it shouldn't be I think he gets
overlooked because he lifted in smaller
weight
you know people want to see the biggest
guys lifting the biggest way possible
and I think that's a shame because I do
think it's pretty cool how smaller guys
are able to lift enormous weights but at
the same time now that I am trying to
add almost mess I see that it doesn't
help you as much as you might think like
adding 30 pounds to your list while
adding 30 pounds to your body weight
won't necessarily make your lifts go up
a hundred so I have appreciation for
both sides but yeah I do it I do wish
the smaller let's just got more
recognition so so just out of curiosity
why Lamar Gant instead of someone like
Hideki Inaba or like in more modern
times
feda Cinco or Olek oh I guess you didn't
I thought I were thinking you were
thinking somebody that I studied
specifically and I didn't I you know I
was pretty focused on American lifters
no fair enough who do you personally
think is super impressive that maybe no
one has heard about because I assume
most of our lifters are going to look
most of our listeners are going to be at
least somewhat familiar with Lamar can't
so who's who's kind of like either a
super super old school physical
culturist or like a more obscure lifter
who's done something that you find super
impressive that that more people should
know about yeah I mean I would still
deferred about people's their you know
Sandow is definitely somebody to study
he actually many many people have
studied Sandow and the feats that he
performer pretty cool but again back
before formal records were recorded you
could really make up what the amounts
that you were lifting and nobody would
able to call be able to call you out on
them so I always take those older guys
with a grain of salt
fair enough all right so moving on to
somewhat new territory I guess we have
touched on this a little bit and it's a
question we talked about before we
started recording and you said very
understandably that there's no way you
could get into all of it but just in
general how have opinions on strength
training changed over time and how has
portrayal of strength training and being
big and muscular changed over time
because it it seems like back in the day
it used to be something that was cool
and then kind of cardio and aerobics had
a had a big day in the Sun in the 80s
and 90s and you know now there's more
superhero movies more interest in
resistance training again it seems so
like how have those opinions shifted and
what seemed to be some of the factors
driving those shifts over time yeah so I
think we've already covered you know the
kind of the ordinance physical culture
and then how it spread following World
War two I think you can really look at
the media following World War two and
see a lot of really very interesting
ways that popular culture have has
influenced strength training what my
very favorite example is the advent of
superheroes and particularly Superman
and the Superman comics because you look
at Superman in the 1940s and 50s and he
looks almost like a normal guy and then
you look at Superman today and he looks
like you know he would put Kai green to
shame and that coincided with the that
that change in how Superman was
portrayed coincided with the
proliferation of anabolic steroids so
that I think is something that's very
very interesting to look at and also you
know when you look at the way that
health and fitness have been kind of
conflated with each other I think that
is almost entirely driven by the media
because you have images of and this this
you can trace back very very far but you
have images in magazines and TV shows of
whether it's a professional bodybuilder
whether it's a fitness model whatever
the case may be of hey this person looks
beautiful therefore they are healthy and
when in reality you know what that
person did to look that way was probably
very unhealthy and I I would contribute
that almost entirely to the media when
you look at strength training in
particular I think again the superhero
thing was pretty big I think that Arnold
and the guys that I mentioned the movies
were very very big in that and so
I could go on for a very very long time
I think he specifically mentioned the
cardio boom that though was more driven
by fears of health actual concerns over
health um when president I should really
know this off the top of my head I want
to say President Eisenhower had a heart
attack on a golf course that really
raised fears of this silent killer that
men in the United States were unfit
because they had too much stress in
their lives they didn't have enough
physical activity and that really
coincided with some of the space
programs some of the other things that
people needed to be fit for and so all
of that kind of gave rise to two
aerobics to running and to that that
area of physical culture and so again I
could it's an extraordinarily difficult
question because again you could spend a
lifetime studying this stuff and so
hopefully those few examples are kind of
interesting for people want to look them
up on their own but to dive into even
any one of them you could write a whole
dissertation one that makes sense I
think that kind of comes to an end of
the pre-prepared questions we had did
you have anything left Asterix no I will
say when when you said a fear of health
about that cardio boom I thought you
said a fear of hell well and I thought
this was gonna circle all the way back
around a muscular Christianity I was on
the edge of my seat man I like that that
could be in my alternative history my
alternative dissertation we are all
sinners in the hands of an angry god but
if you can maintain a six-minute mile
pace you can escape that hand I'm going
to hell no that was the way my ear heard
it I was like I can't wait to see where
this goes
I'm sorry I feel like we could write
physical culture fanfic about it I think
that's already been done right I don't
know I II will admit to be to being
fully out of the loop when it comes to
lifting related fanfic I'm sure there's
a community for it
so then we want to stay respectful of
your time you've been here for for over
an hour at this point is there anything
you would like to leave the listeners
with just in terms of closing thoughts
you know I I don't know that I want to
leave the listeners with this but I do
want to thank you guys for the
information you put out I think one of
the things that really gets to me in the
fitness industry is how much terrible
information there is and so what you
guys are doing with the website with the
podcast with mass I really really
appreciate it I think that you are
making the industry better for everyone
you know regardless of how that
knowledge is you use the fact that
you're putting out good stuff is very
very important to me so I wanted to
thank you all for that
well that that honestly means a lot
you're you're one of a relatively small
handful of people in the industry who I
feel incredibly confident pointing
people towards knowing that you will
also pervade good information their way
so that that honestly does mean a whole
lot coming from you and Ben he doesn't
say that to every guest no like two
prior guests have have tried to feed me
that line and it's just like cool thanks
[Laughter]
just kidding maybe so
alright just kind of in closing where
can people find you how can people
connect with you and your media empire
probably the best easiest way is just
Instagram my my name is pH deadlift from
there that's probably the easiest way to
find me my I tried to use that pretty
consistently so that it's easy fine you
can check out my website at pH deadlift
calm and if you have questions you can
email me a Ben at pH deadlift or column
so it's all pretty pretty
straightforward and you know I'm happy
to do my best to help like I said most
of this stuff is individual so you know
broad questions are kind of difficult to
answer but I'll do my best
sweet well thank you so much for coming
on thanks for having me guys I really
appreciate it thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it
visit stronger by science comm to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you